whoa whoa jk non-natural loop i just forgot where my scene
was hello or good night this is good night dragoons again we
are back let me know the bgm is um at a okay volume everyone
i always forget i always i always don't not forget i always
don't know if it's if it's too loud or too quiet so just
feel free to let me know um tonight is a chill stream
because it's good night dragon one so he's just mostly
hanging out yapp a bit i don't know yapp a lot actually um i
messed up and i forgot to use the bathroom so uh i guess
chill a little bit because i gotta pee i was like oh wait i
knew i forgot something i forgot to use the bathroom okay
well at least get the lovely bgm i'll be right back guys
all right i'm back everyone back from bathroom break oh i
feel so relaxed today um i which i shouldn't be because i
should have a lot of work to do today i'm supposed to record
something really quick um last minute but i had to do a lot
of work in between not to get food because i forgot to eat
lunch i was like i must have forgotten something and i
realized oh i didn't eat And I was like, oh, shit.
I knew I forgot something.
So I had to get food.
I went out to eat because I wanted to treat myself for, you
know, beating a video game.
I was like, I did it.
Oh, my God.
I beat a video game.
I got to treat myself for a job well done.
Oh, such good hard work, Doki.
You worked so hard beating that video game on stream.
You did so well, Doki.
Letting that lady die so you could live.
I mean, she was dead anyway, but not saving her life.
Good job, Doki.
Treat yourself.
For real.
Okay, but honestly, bro, okay.
That's so weird because I remember I was just thinking like
the no players online.
I was like, is that what coders do?
Like, like basically it's like, bro, I don't know what's
going on with the coding.
the same bugs and there you guys like look bro you forgot to
transfuse the soul of an eight-year-old girl and that's why
your texture isn't loading properly I'm like what the I'm
like what the fuck yes they some they make the deal with the
moussein to be able to code anything like yeah it's so
accurate exactly that's why all the coders are always so
fucking depressed because they sold their soul to
Of course, it's so simple.
You have to appease the machine spirits.
Also, I watched the newest episode of Fiona and Cake.
I don't know how to feel about the series.
I don't know.
I think season one was really good because, like, you know,
you haven't seen, you get to see, like, the, you get to see,
like, the original cast.
of adventure time again you know with like fiona not fiona
sorry uh with like princess bubblegum marceline and finn and
stuff like that and then introduced like fiona they
reintroduced fiona and kate but it's i i do not like fiona
no she's a bitch like i really don't like her um she's just
so unlikable but finn is so likable that's the thing it
makes me really sad because you know you're She's not Finn.
She's like Fiona.
She's her own character, but she's like, she's such, I don't
know She's like they gave her so many flaws that she's just
unlikable as a character in itself Because she does, you
know, you're like, oh, she's very very flawed, but I'm like,
yeah, she's so fucking flawed that I don't even want her as
a friend like I don't even she seems like a terrible friend
like Who?
Okay, so if anyone knows Adventure Time, so everyone knows
Adventure Time, right?
Like the Pendleton Ward series where at first it was just
like, at first it was just like each episode, it's his own
thing.
And it's just like whimsical adventures of a little boy and
his dog.
And then they end up making it more and more plot heavy.
And then you found out, oh my God, it's based off of like
earth after like maybe like a couple thousand years after
like a nuclear bomb exploded on earth um and then like what
happens with that with the last surviving human quote
unquote um and everything and it's just it's just like crazy
adventures and everything and there's like a lot later on i
got a lot better but i introduced like actual plot into the
show because no one expected it um and then a lot of like
character building and stuff and it was a
those who don't know um we wouldn't have event we wouldn't
have all the modern cartoon shows like modern cartoon shows
that everyone talks about now if it wasn't for flapjack
because all of the current modern cartoons that are that's
our beloved basically you can trace it back to flapjack
because all the all the show renders come from flapjack and
then from flapjack the current modern okay i won't say like
modern cartoons like i think adventure time is like um last
gen's modern cartoon now the current gen cartoon comes from
adventure time so a lot of the current showrunners actually
come from adventure time but um last gen last gen's modern
like cartoon shows that were beloved came from flapjack and
i know it's like a weird chart like if you look through a
flow chart of all the shit where all they come where they
all come from like all the showrunners trace it all the way
back to flapjack um anyway anyway sorry off topic uh also my
brain is frazzled at the moment because it is 9 p.m and i am
a little tired because i had lots of food so i'm on a food
coma right now um anyway so adventure time ended it was a
really good finale um all the songs are very memorable and
everything um it was very sad that the ending to it was very
sad and then a couple like you know a couple years passed by
and they're like we're gonna bring adventure time back but
we're uh it's gonna be told through fiona and cake um but
the modern um the characters you love so much will will uh
will make a comeback in fiona and cake so people were so
curious you're like oh how are the characters like how is
finn like princess babaga marceline uh jake all come back in
in Fiona cake because Fiona cake is an alternate universe
gender bent version of Jake and Finn so people were so
fucking confused they're like what do you mean um like
they're gonna make appearances in Fiona cake so they
basically basically it's really weird so beyond the premise
it's a little bit of spoilery but Fiona and cake is like
basically uh Simon who was Ice King.
I know some of you guys were like, oh, I never watched this.
Like, I never watched Adventure Time.
So, like, what the fuck is she talking about?
But bear with me.
So, Fiona Cake is actually a fan fiction that the Ice King
slash Simon, that's his actual name, came from.
So, it's all in his mind.
So, the entire world of Fiona and Cake comes from The Ice
King's Mine.
And then Prismo, who is like, I guess like the guardian of
the universe or what?
Okay, I know.
It gets very confusing.
So Prismo, who is like the guardian of the universe, and he
can grant wishes and stuff, he likes to watch too.
So apparently, he really loved the world of Fiona and cake.
So he made it real.
So Prismo was like, I love Fiona and Cake.
Okay, by the way, apparently Fiona and Cake comes from
Prismo.
Okay, this is where it gets super complicated.
So this is what we originally thought.
We're like, oh, Prismo saved Fiona and Cake's world because
he loves Fiona and Cake.
But in actuality, Prismo was the one that created Fiona and
Cake.
to create universes because that's against the rules because
he's only allowed to watch he's not allowed to create um so
so he didn't want to get in trouble with like the universe
police you know like it's like the time police but instead
of the time police it's the universe police so he didn't
want to get in trouble so so he is like i will put this
world of fiona and cake because he was like i'm gonna create
my original content but instead he just it's like it's like
uh 50 shades of where they were like, I'm going to create my
original content, but it was just the fan fiction of
Twilight.
So it's basically like that.
So he's like, I'm going to create an original content.
And he ended up just creating, like, adventure time.
But he just made them all.
He just changed genders off of everyone.
He's like, oh, this wasn't quite original.
Anyway, so he was like, I don't want to get caught.
So he put the entire world of Fiona and cake into the Ice
King's mind.
so um so that's how that's how like fiona kink's world was
born anyway so um after the ice king stopped being crazy and
became like simon again so the ice king was actually a
regular human being but he then he wore a crown and turned
fucking crazy because it's the crazy crown um you're not
like uh the normal person will not be able to like uh will
not be able to like stay sane crown because it makes you go
crazy because it's filled with magical powers and everything
so this regular human being named simon who was an
archaeologist professor he he wore the crown and he got
crazy but he got ice he got like ice powers anyway so
finally at the end of adventure time he became normal again
um because he took the crown off finally uh he he finally
took the crown up and then um his like girlfriend uh took
the crown and then she became a fucking god that that
doesn't really matter in the story at the moment so i know
you're like what the fuck she became a god so okay so here's
another like off off track here like a little sidetrack here
but his girlfriend um tried to save his life but she had to
become a god to save his life and then she like took the
crown away and then he became normal and then she became a
god and then she was like Bye, and then she disappeared.
So, anyway, he's depressed because he lost his girlfriend.
Anyway, but that doesn't really matter.
Like, you know, like, everything he knows about the world is
technically dead.
So does it really matter if it's another person?
Does it really matter?
Like, everyone he knows in love is already dead anyway.
So, like, what's more for one more person?
Um, so, um, um, anyway, um, anyway, so, uh, so he becomes
normal, but because Fiona and Cake was in his mind, she was
everything, yeah, but, but to her, she was, he wasn't,
though, like, he, she, he was just an experience, that's the
worst, I mean, I cried when he said that, okay, so there
was, like, this really touching moment, where to Simon she
was like everything to him and to her she was like yeah you
were just an experience but like it's like it hits hard like
it you know what like I say it sounds like bro you're such a
like you would think Betty you're a bitch but like but like
she did she sacrificed everything for Simon but Simon like
didn't put her at first priority priority at all like she
was like oh I could she was like oh I could like I have this
really cool scholarship opportunity where I could actually
like follow my dreams and do the things I want to do and
then Simon was like yeah but what about my studies you could
stay here instead you know and then obviously you know Betty
was like oh you know what Simon I love you I'm gonna I'm
gonna stay with yeah she gave
and then she was like you know what you're right simon let
me just ditch my dreams i will not follow my dreams and
follow you instead it was so sad like um anyway so yeah so
like after like you know he like met betty again like you
know she's like the god of chaos and um he was like he had
to finally let her go because she's like bro we can't keep
doing this bro i'm literally the god of chaos now like we
can't be together anymore you gotta move on you know like
she wants him to move on but simon's like but betty i can
save you and then later on like he finally moves on he's
like you were my everything and then betty was like you were
an experience and then bye bye like it's so actually cried
though i was like oh my god simon she gave you everything
and then you took it for granted and when you finally
realized how much she gave you she moves on how you fuck you
fumbled it bro you fucking fumbled it like and uh it was a
wonderful experience she still said experience like
okay anyway sorry i got off track here that wasn't uh part
of the that wasn't part of the recap but i actually cried
when that i actually cried watching that part because it was
it was so because like it was so fucked up um anyway so um
fuck where was that at the recap okay so okay simon is
normal now he is a normal human being and he's not fucking
crazy anymore um but because he is not crazy anymore um the
fiona cake world in his head is now like regular world so
it's not like magical or anything it's no they no longer
like cake is a regular cat instead of like a magical
stretchy cat and everything and uh you know they're in they
live in a fucking boring human world so um so it changed
it's no longer magical because simon's no longer fucking
crazy like the ice king so it's just a normal world um So,
so, so we followed that and then like, and then, and then
like, um, in this crazy quest on, I don't remember.
So basically like, they somehow took the word out of Simon's
head and then like Fiona and Kate became like real people.
Like it's, it's fucking trippy.
I know like you're like, what the fuck is she talking about?
but they took the world because Prismo planted a world
inside Simon's head and then he took the world out of his
head and now it's a real universe now um it's it's a real
universe and so so fion and cake are real people and and
marshal lee who is the gender-bent version of marshaling the
vampire queen he's voiced by Donald Glover.
If you guys don't know who Donald Glover is, he's Childish
Gambino.
If you don't know who Childish Gambino is, he's Troy from
Community.
If you don't know Troy from Community, he's the guy who's
like, where wolf by mitzvah, bump, spooky, scary, men
becoming woes, woes be okay, so he sang that too.
He also is in Atlanta, the show.
All right, anyway, and he did, Anyway, so, um...
So, anyway, so, so, it's all like the...
And also Neil Patrick Harris was Prince Gumball, but they
recasted him, and then they...
Okay, so this is what appeased me, I'm sorry, I'm only like
bouncing everywhere, but I'm watching this, I'm watching
Fiona and Kate right now, and I don't know if I like it or
not, because, like, season one was good.
Season one, it was good.
Season two is, like, all over the place.
I'm not really sure if I...
still don't know if I like it or not but I did I'm so upset
because they've recasted Prince Gumball three fucking times
and I'm like oh my god like I get it like the first two
actors they casted were like super big actors because like
the first one was like was Neil Patrick Harris and then the
second one is the guy from Pitch Perfect I don't know how
else to explain him he's that guy in Pitch perfect like you
remember his voice is everywhere.
He's all okay.
He's that guy.
He's the gay.
Okay He's the gay guy in the big mouth He's the gay kid in
big mouth.
You understand if you know his voice you understand who his
voice is Um Anyway, um, um, so so so and then they recasted
him again In Season 3, I don't even know who the fuck is
this guy in Season 3 Like it's not like it's not like you
know usually when they recast someone they try to make sure
They try to make sure like they sound the same But every
time they recast him it's literally a different voice And it
pisses me off because it's like I don't know I just I went
it just doesn't it just puts me out of immersion You know
I'm just like why like like It, I hate it I don't like how
they, there's no, it's no, not consistent at all.
Like, they don't even try to match the voice.
It's just, they just, it's like, it's like they just find a
gay actor.
It throws me up.
I think it's like, it's like, don't worry, at least the
actor's gay.
And I'm like, that's not the point.
That's not the fucking point.
At least make them sound the same.
Like I don't care if the voice actor is gay or not.
Because he's playing a gay character.
I was like I don't care.
I just want them to sound the same.
Like so that is.
So I just I just don't care.
Like.
so um so anyway um so but it's just they all sound different
like i did not that hard to like try and keep it consistent
if you're gonna like recast them three times at least make
two of them sound similar but they don't they don't make
them sound similar at all and it pisses me off That's like,
also they recasted, uh, Marshall Lee as well.
Um, but at least the thing is, it's not noticeable at all.
Um, Donald, they got, I don't know if you guys noticed, but
Donald Glover had a heart attack last, last year.
Um, because like, he's like super fucking stressed out and
everything.
Um, so like, um, so like he had a heart attack last year,
apparently.
And that's why he like, he had to, like, he had to back out
in like a lot of projects and stuff.
Yeah, during, like, his tour.
That's why he had, like, had to cancel his tour that he had
to do.
I think, like, yeah, he's, like, a huge workaholic.
And so he had, like, yeah, he recently had a stroke.
So that's why, like, it's understandable.
It was a stroke.
Sorry, a stroke.
Not a heart.
It was a stroke, but it's quite similar.
Isn't a stroke and a heart attack sort of similar?
Like, it's related to heart.
It's related to heart issues.
um oh are they different things oh sorry sorry i meant a
stroke um and um sorry i don't know the difference between a
heart attack and a stroke i always thought they were the
same uh i always thought oh that's in the brain okay that's
a lot worse okay that that is a lot worse i thought a stroke
is for the heart uh because it sounds like it's in the heart
you know uh but yeah no apparently it's a lot worse than a
heart now i know it's a lot worse than a heart attack um
Anyway, so that's why he has to back out of a lot of
projects and they had to like recast him for Adventure time
because he had to pick and choose like what he can and can't
do Because, you know, like he had to rest and everything.
He can't do a lot of work stuff anymore Um, and uh, yeah,
and yeah, both are really bad regardless.
But anyway, so he Uh, he had to, you know, he couldn't do it
Marshal Lee anymore.
But the thing is they're Lee, but he literally sounds, he is
so good.
The new guy he got, the new guy, the new guy they got for
Marshall Lee sounds exactly like Donald Glover.
And the only reason I knew that they recasted Donald Glover
is because it, it like showed up on my for you Twitter page,
because they were like, wait, Donald Glover wasn't credited,
um, during like the, um, in the, IMDB credits like wait does
that mean he's not gonna be an adventure time like for this
next new season so that's the only reason why I knew I knew
that he got recasted because if I listen to it it literally
sounds like him and I didn't even know but Prince Gumball
every voice is different and it pisses me off because it's
not consistent I it's like it might as well be a fucking new
character that's the worst part it's so different from each
other it might as well be a nude character like it's not
even gumball like it's i i don't think i don't know i it's
just it appeased me so much because i just wish i like you
know every time someone gets recasted they usually try to
like match the voice as closely as possible but never
gumball i don't understand like who the fuck are you Anyway,
sorry, I got off track here.
so, Beacon and Cake end up being like its own little
character.
It's like they're their own characters, their own
personalities, their own like their own history and story.
Okay, the weirdest, okay, I need to talk about this plot
boy.
So, for those who know Adventure Time or don't know
Adventure Time, there's Jake, Jake the Dog, and his wife,
Princess Rainicorn.
I assume that's what...
Rainicorn.
Right?
Yeah, Lady...
Sorry, Lady Rainicorn.
She's technically a princess, I feel like.
So, it's like husband and wife.
And Lady Rainicorn is literally a rainbow unicorn that
flies.
Anyway, so...
In the...
Yeah, the Korean...
The Korean rainbow unicorn.
Anyway, so...
In the gender-bent version...
um so cake ends up being a magical cat again um i don't know
it's fucking weird because prismo was like bam you're a
magical cat and then she kept all her powers in the in the
in the normal world um and like people don't find that
fucking weird that's a magical stretching talking cat anyway
so so so the gender bent version of lady rainicorn is lord
monochrome i think i think that's called I think that's his
name.
Is that, is that his name?
Yeah, Lord Monochromicorn.
Oh my god, never mind.
That's even fucking more worse.
Okay, so his name is Lord Monochromicorn and it's the gender
bent version of Lady Rainicorn, but that's just a fucking
man.
So they don't make him like, make him like an actual like
you know horse or anything it's literally a man and then
like cake is like flirting with him and everything and
they're sort of like dating and i'm like bro
i'm like i'm like i'm honestly a little uncomfortable with
that storyline like I guess because it's like that's a cat
and you're a man but but they're trying to make it like a
romantic like love story and I'm like he's a man
yeah so I'll see if I can get I'll get like a screencast and
then like cake a fucking cat by the way has like a dream
where she's pregnant and like you know lord monochrome
mccoran is there like as a man just being like oh i'm here
to support you and then she gives birth to fucking cats and
i'm like this is no no i'm like no i do not like this okay
okay here Here you go.
This is so fucking weird.
I don't know.
That also weirds me out.
That's why, like, I don't know how I feel about Fiona and
Jake.
I really don't know.
Season 2 is goddamn weird.
It's so fucking weird.
I literally just watched the newest episode.
Like, like, I... Like, it's like, oh.
It's like, what is this?
Like, it's like, my thing is, she doesn't look like this 24.
for she only like um transforms into like like a cat woman
when she's near him but like this is what she actually looks
like like you know like a cat so this is what fio like cake
looks like um when she's not like transformed and then
you'll be like oh yeah no that's fucking weird yeah like
this is what she looks like when she's not like in flirty
mode by the way let me grab the screenshot so when she's not
like flirty horny mode this is like what she looks like
so and then okay let me see okay cake dream lord
monochromacorn um yeah you guys see the Can I see the issue
right now?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's a straight up fucking cat.
All right, let me find the...
Okay, Fiona and cake.
Wait.
Cake, scene, dream.
Dream, there you go.
Where is it?
I gotta find that clip.
I need to find that clip.
Cats.
Okay, or is it kittens?
Kidden babies.
Let me see.
Kitten.
Oh, babies.
There we go.
Okay, here.
Okay, let me make sure.
Let me turn off my...
The crow mobile, yes, here, yo.
Let me see.
Let me grab this clip.
Wait.
all right here we go all right here we go let's see like she
fucking gives births to baby kittens and it's fucking weird
it's like a dream this is by the way this is all a dream for
her but like it's implying I'm like bro he he banged the cat
I was just like I was just like bro bro he banged the cat
Bro, like, I...
There's nothing else I can say.
What else can I say?
Yeah.
Anyway, so...
That's my...
That's, like, one of my gripes about Fiona and Cake.
That's, like...
I have a lot of issues with the newest season, but, like,
this is one of my issues here.
Just because, like, why did...
I don't know.
I just don't know.
I just don't fuck with that.
It's just weird.
It was actually just weird.
Anyway.
so like that's like one of my issues um i need you to
explain to me how it's better if he's a unicorn and said
nexi thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
because at least it's like an animal and like at least it's
an animal and like i don't know it's further away from I'll
say it's further away from bestiality It doesn't make it
Obviously it doesn't make it better But at least it's not
bestiality Like
That's what I mean At least it's not that There's still like
other reasons wrong But at least it's not that like true and
real so um yeah and also she was originally a fucking cat
like like it's only because prisma was like zap you're not a
fucking regular cat that like that that happened like one
season ago it was just a cat like a real fucking cat she
literally has been sentient for like maybe like two months
that's also a problem she had sentience for two months guys
um um oh my god what else what else was what else did i have
grapes about oh yeah but anyway yeah Fiona is just
incredibly unlikable.
Like the new, the new episode with her, she is just, like,
she's just so unlikable.
You, like, I get, like, the writers want to be like, yeah,
but she's very flawed as a character, just to be more
relatable.
And I'm like, I don't even want her as a friend.
She's a bad friend.
She's a very, very bad friend.
Like, um, Savior.
Thank you for the magenta soup, but they can thank you Babe,
I'm breaking up with you.
It's not you.
You were poggers.
It's me.
I'm Omega I'm sorry.
This is Pepe.
Oh my god You know, like I won't be surprised I won't be
surprised if
And if like Oh my god, what are the new gen?
It's gen alpha, right?
I won't be surprised if that's something Gen Alpha kids
would say, unironically.
A relationship has been weird chat for months.
It's time to end it, no kappa.
Thank you, magenta, super.
Thank you, thank you.
Because it's like, okay, you guys, okay, look.
I know I'm going to make you guys cringe.
But you know, like, the 6-7 joke?
So it's, you guys, for those who don't know, it started like
a year.
I think the 6-7 joke started, like, a year ago.
But, like, for Gen Alpha and, like, Zoomers, they actually
thought it was funny like not unironically it's like it they
all thought it was actually funny funny um because like they
you know but now now everyone like everyone in all the
generations know what six seven is and now everyone just
says it because people think it's like i'm not like it's
ironic humor now yeah um yeah now it's everywhere because
now everyone was like
It's so cringe to the fact that people find it funny now
because it's ironic humor now.
So it's like how people thought like 69 was cringe and now
everyone says ha ha 69 because it's like ironic humor.
It now went full circle.
It made it into my Christmas card theme.
I still don't know what 6-7 is.
6-7 is basically what's from some rapper.
lyric and then some kid was like made a meme about it like
like in his generation like gen alpha and everything yeah
see everyone's everyone's now like nice like we're all like
nice but you're 69 but when it first became a thing when 69
first became a thing everyone would be like oh man you're so
cringe bro but now it went full circle and now it's funny
because it's like ironically funny And now 67 is doing that
thing now too Because people say 67 as a way to be like
ironically funny But it's so cringe because we're not at
that It took 69 a couple of years to make it there So just
give 67 a bit of time And then we'll all be like Ha ha 67 I
know you guys all think it's cringe right now But give it a
couple of more months for it to cook And then you're gonna
start seeing it unironically Or ironically You're gonna
start seeing it ironically Just give it a couple of months
for it to cook.
Just like Skippity Toilet.
We're all like, oh, cringe.
But then people are like, ha ha, look, I got Skippity
Toilet.
You're like, oh, yeah, ha ha.
You said it was, I know somebody like, I still think it's
cringe now.
But people do use it as an ironic, funny thing.
It always goes full circle.
At one point, it goes so cringe that it becomes ironically
funny.
you find skibbity funny i don't i've never even watched the
videos of where skibbity toilet comes from i find it funny
now because i find it ironically funny to the because i
bought skibbity toilet as a fortnite cosmetic so every time
i bring it out i think it's fucking hilarious because i'd be
like guys look i have skibbity toilet it's my backpack guys
and it's just a great it's like a great like
Because it's great.
Whenever I bring up Fortnite, I'd be like, look, guys, I got
Skibity Toilet as my backpack.
And it's a good icebreaker.
Because it's fucking so stupid that it's funny.
Apparently, as Lord and the Creator is improving their
animation.
Oh, someone doesn't know the newest update.
The Creator lost all rights to Skibity Toilet.
Michael Bay owns it now.
I still don't know understand how the fuck Michael Bay is
going to make that a movie but we'll see in like two to
three years I guess yeah how oh for those who don't know um
basically like uh the creator signed the I guess he like was
so greedy I guess he didn't have someone fucking looking at
the contracts or something he didn't get real lawyer to look
through the contracts because Hollywood contracts are very
predatory no Michael Bay is a fucking terrible person for
those who don't know the actual lore behind Michael Bay he
makes great like dumb movies but like he's an actual
terrible person um she okay you guys might be like oh but he
discovered like Megan Fox and whatever no apparently he was
like a huge creep towards like Megan Fox during like the
filming of Transformers and like he was actually he's like
actually like incredibly creepy and like allegedly a really
bad person yeah um and then apparently try to ruin megan
fox's career right after like uh right after that um but
like uh but like anyway so um i'm not surprised because it's
hollywood and a lot of hollywood contracts are incredibly
like predatory um because it's all up there you know what
Hollywood wants is to just make as much money as possible
and pay the least amount of money possible to other people
um because that's Hollywood baby um and that's why like um a
lot of actors and actresses tend to not make money from the
film uh like current for those who don't know current movie
contracts for those who don't have good lawyers like for
like actors and actresses who don't have like good lawyers
or like good agents a lot of them don't make money if their
movie succeeds in the box office um because hollywood would
uh push for contracts that would either be like just payment
uh for like just like you know like a flat fee or or they
would do a payment style where um they pay based off how
well based off how well a movie does in box office and
streaming.
But then they will purposely be like, oh, the movie did
really terrible.
So, like, I guess we don't have to pay you anything.
But then, like, obviously the movie would seem like a box
office success.
But then they're like, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Look, look, see, look at the finances.
Look, guys.
Look, see, it says we made negative money.
Because, like, because, like, we spent it all.
during production and advertising and we didn't make enough
in the in the theaters in the box office but in the end um
in the end a lot of these movie companies they would open a
shell company and then like pay like they'll be like they'll
open like a shell company that would be like oh provides uh
camera equipment to the production team like it's like their
own shell company like it's their own producer shell company
where they'll be like oh yeah see we paid this by them like
500 000 for like the production of everything so like all
that money went over there so oh i'm sorry so like if we
look at all the finances and subtract everything like we
technically barely broke even so because of that we can't
pay you um this we can't pay you the amount because
technically the movie didn't do well enough to um to even
make a profit yeah no it's really fucked up there's like a
really good video that um that talks about it how's that
even legal um um that's very easy to explain um Hollywood is
filled with incredibly rich people and in order for those
incredibly rich people to keep being incredibly rich they
have really good lawyers to make
tiny toes welcome to the tomato farm welcome welcome um yeah
it's just lots of loopholes uh bird thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you uh just i want to say you're
amazing thank you super chat thank you thank you i really
appreciate it we guys have been enjoying the stream so far
yeah like they have yeah the best lawyers so um so that's
why i I'm not surprised that that the Skibity toilet creator
literally by the way his the YouTube channel isn't even
owned by him now it's owned by Michael Bay so Michael Bay
owns this man's channel because he signed he literally
signed away all his rights to Michael Bay so Michael Bay
owns everything now and he has not been paid like Since he
signed the contract with them so like all those
merchandising deals like the movie the merchandising deals
the fucking fortnight cop Yes, I funded Michael Bay to be
fair.
I bought the fucking cosmetic before he before he revealed
That he lost his all his rights to Michael Bay.
Okay guys.
I did not know I was funding Michael Bay I legitimately did
not know because nobody knew until like last month and I
bought that cosmetic at least five months ago I just just a
disclaimer if I knew Michael Bay now owns Skippity Toilet I
would not have bought I would not have bought the cosmetic
um shake my head Toki and do better Yeah, so, no, you got a
lot of, you got a lot of money out of fucking Zoomers who
took their parents' credit cards for sure.
You would, you would.
No, I would not.
I would not.
It's also why I have not played Poppy's Playtime.
Because I felt really weird playing it because of all the
drama surrounding Poppy's Playtime.
I don't know if it's, like, when it first came up.
Like, I do have some integrity.
Nango, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
First, Shupa, just to say this is an epic anti-Bay Hollywood
rant.
What drama?
I don't know if it's, like, if it's, like, okay now.
Like, I haven't seen, like, the current, I didn't read the
current update.
But, like, for those who don't know, the original creators
of Poppy Playtime, They used to come from, like, they used
to make FNAF parodies.
Or not just FNAF parody.
They used to do, like, like, Kid Slop, I think.
I think that's, what's the word for them?
Oh, what's the, what's the word for it?
It's like, is it Kid Slop?
Is that the proper term for it?
Where it's, like, brain rot videos?
No, it's like, they're like, like, those brain rot YouTube
videos.
Like, content farm.
Yeah, so...
They used to be, like, semi-content farm accounts originally
before they made Poppy Playtime.
And it would be, like, content farm of, like, you know,
Minecraft,
FNAF, I don't remember.
I just remember Minecraft and FNAF.
They used to do that.
And apparently, they used to be like...
They used to be like...
They used to have, like, a channel where they make fun of...
other 3D animators back then.
Like, I think like half of the creators.
I don't know if it's like all the creators.
But I think like some of the creators of Poppy Playtime.
They used to have a channel where they literally do like
CinemaSins.
But instead of CinemaSins on like movies.
They did it on like other indie animators.
So they were like assholes.
Yeah, they were like fucking assholes.
But people were like, oh, they were really young back then.
or something.
I don't remember.
Yeah.
So it was like a couple of years ago.
Yeah, no.
So they were like actual like assholes.
Yeah.
And they were like bullying like underage animators.
They were bullying like underage kids who were trying to,
who were like aspiring animators with it and stuff.
Yeah.
So it was like, they were just punching down and stuff.
And so that's why like when, because I knew about that, and
then they made poppy's playtime and that's why i have never
played poppy's playtime because i just didn't i didn't like
i didn't like that um there i didn't like that they they
like used to do that back then and um they got called out
for it a while like a long time ago when chapter one first
came out uh when chapter one first came out they got like
called out for it and stuff and like you know people
uncovered a lot about him being like yeah no that's really
fucked up because that they did private a bunch of those
videos when it happened because you know they're like oh
like after a while they apologized um they apologized and
were like yeah like we regret everything we did back then
and stuff like that because they actually like they kept
doing it to like one animator and then he got like he got
like super like depressed and everything and like like it
was actually like cyberbullying and stuff like that and um
it was only when they got called out that they private a
bunch of those like videos when they because like it's the
thing Um, that made me like not really Um, no, they'd stop
doing it Obviously because they have Poppy's playtime now
Like they don't have to do that shit anymore Like they have
their fucking Um, their content farm now They have their Um,
their golden ticket It's literally, they have their golden
ticket now They don't have to do that anymore Um, because
they can just merchandise Poppy playtime For the rest of
their lives Until like, you know, for like Possibly at least
20 years Because of finale Yeah, they're their own big IP
now so um so they don't they don't have to like worry about
doing that anymore um but obviously um in chapter one um
after chapter one release you know everybody was like oh my
god it's so like what are you it's still like i would say
like it's not really a unique concept because it's still
like a mascot like you know it's still like the typical
horror genre where you get a mascot character but what if
they're evil so um i won't say it's quite a unique concept
but it is like Like, you know, like it checks all the boxes
of what children want.
Of what, like what makes a good IP that kids would love.
And wow, you can merchandise it and shit.
Yeah, the mascot horror market.
Because it's like, it's great for merchandising.
It's like a great cash cow.
But that's why I've never touched Poppy's playtime.
Because I've always felt super uncomfortable about like the
creators and stuff.
um maybe i mean they did apologize but it was only like
afterwards where like they had a lot of controversies with
like you know the they also like at that time too um at that
time too um they had that nft drama as well so that's why
i'm like oh you know i was just like oh i don't really want
to touch it because like you know they got called out for
the the whole like bullying like like underage indie
animators and also um the whole nft thing so that's why like
for me i've never like touched poppy's playtime because of
it i do enjoy it i like the concept itself is like i know
like i was just like oh it's just not really that um um i've
always loved like reanimated uh reanimated plushies like
that's like one of my favorite what's the word one of my
favorite tropes in general, even though I know it's like,
oh, it's just like a cash grab merchandising cash cow thing
for, um, for people, but I've always loved the reanimated,
uh, toys trope because it's, it's such a cute idea.
Um, I mean, it's horror, but like, it's such a cute and
interesting idea.
And I always love seeing designs of that and everything.
Um, so that really sucks, you know, I have always wanted to,
you know, play time but i just don't with the creators and
that's why i've never played the game i don't think i will
um just because of that um it's also similar to some people
would be like what about doom like oh doki how come you've
never played doom on stream or like because it's such a
classic game and um it's such a classic game and it's like
um it's like you know um something that everyone like um
everyone talks about when they talk about like you know fps
genres and stuff so at that time when i wanted to play doom
it was when there was the music drama going on yeah so
apparently yeah so that's also why i've never touched doom
as well and i was just waiting to see if that ever got
resolved until like then for me to try doom but it's also
because they They screwed over the music producer, the
original music producer for Doom, who's created all the
original soundtrack for the most memorable Doom songs.
And when I wanted to play Doom, that news broke out.
So I was like, oh, okay, that timing really sucked.
Because I actually really wanted to play Doom.
And then there was like, and then the whole controversy,
broke out with the the original music producer of doom so i
never got a chance to try it out because of it yeah it was
incredibly bad timing that felt really bad for uh for mick
because you know he was um he was like you know the
originator of like some of the most memorable doomed music
out there uh yeah so that's why i didn't wasn't ever able to
try out i think it was doom eternal I don't mind Maybe I
don't mind Trying out like Doom Like Doom games that didn't
screw over Mick Gordon Yeah So I don't know I need to
research that I need to research like which Doom games
Didn't screw over Mr. Gordon
So I have to like research that the classic doom games yeah
so doom one to three which sucks i always wanted to try the
modern ones too because the modern ones look really good as
well but i don't know it's i i just have like i guess i have
like this integrity i guess like um i just feel really off
about supporting like you know supporting companies that do
stuff like that and that's why you see me not touch some
certain game series um if i feel like i just don't want to i
just don't want to support like i just don't want to support
a brand that's like that okay so so basically i'm not like
michael bay
so in conclusion that makes me very different from michael
bay
um let's see x factor thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you uh speaking finnaf i watched finnaf too and i
enjoyed it so based on the finnaf tweet you posted i think
you were listening to the credits and not the fans thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you yeah i know i know
like finnaf one has always got like um i remember finnaf one
got really shitty reviews um when first came up because the
creator is so unsanit because like finnaf was mostly made
for was made for fans also i'm sorry for those who didn't
watch them oh the audios went a bit weird no it's because i
was talking through this so hey guys this is my new water
bottle and it has literally two two liters of water so i was
literally drinking water when i was talking
I don't want to lie to you guys so for those who do not for
those who don't watch member streams I'm not gonna lie to
people who aren't members who did not are also or who are
members and did not watch my FNAF watch along stream but I
did not enjoy FNAF 1 as much as people think I did
it's just I'm I'm sorry
You're right.
It's because she loved it.
Okay.
So, look, to watch, the thing is, I think if I watched it by
myself, I would have, I would definitely not be as happy.
But I think for Nap is the type of movie that you have to
watch with your friends or you won't have or okay it's
either you have to watch with your friends or or you have uh
or as someone who is very very very into finaf to be able to
enjoy it because like there were so many parts and moments
in finaf one where i was just like what the There are so
many plows.
I know, you guys, you're like, Toki, you're supposed to
watch this movie with, like, with your brain turn off, God.
Like, bro, you're supposed to watch it with your brain turn
off.
You're not supposed to think too hard.
But, you, bro, okay, you cannot justify.
There is one scene you cannot fucking defend.
And it's that scene where the kid was like, I know what to
do to save, save everyone.
And she fucking just drew a picture the wall and then and
then bam the the animatronics are freed now and i was like
what the just like you cannot defend that scene like what
the fuck was that there was no like build up or lead to it
there was no hints on like that was the solution yeah one
drawing just changes everything and that was like that was
the scene where i was like there's no way anyone can defend
that scene because it because it's like i like there was no
build-up there's no it was there's no mystery to stop like
you there's it's like you know you keep oh maybe like
there's hints about it there's foreshadowing that this was
what you have to do to like um free the animatronics from um
foreshadowing that led to this also what the fuck happened
to her aunt okay also that part too what the fuck happened
to her dead aunt like they just left her body in their in
their house and then like what happened to her like is she
still alive or is she dead like she's just gone and then
we're supposed to believe that there's the happy ending like
i is she just dead i guess like oh okay i'll find out that
too okay okay we'll find out at part two okay apparently
part two explains what happened okay but can you answer i
don't care i don't care if you spoil me x factor is she
alive or dead like that's all want to know because that was
the that was also another plot point for me the plot hole
for me where i was like what the fuck happened to the aunt
like i need to know is she dead or oh she's dead okay so why
the fuck were they so happy the day after like what did they
like drag the did they just like put the aunt's dead body in
the corner and be like it's time for school
because it's really like the next day and they're like yeah
she's hanging out and talking to people now after knowing
that her fucking aunt was dead like okay anyway yeah they
hated yeah they hated her but it's still a dead person dead
like oh my god wouldn't that give trauma
You might hate someone, but it's still a fucking dead human
body that died in your home.
I'd be pretty traumatized if like some fucks anybody, I
don't care if I hate them or not, but if somebody died in my
home and I was living there and I was still there living in
that house and there was a dead fucking body like in the
room next door.
I'd have trauma.
I don't care.
Stop thinking.
Stop using logic.
Okay.
So, so yeah, no, that's like one of my issues about that.
That was like, there was some issues I had with the movie,
but the dead aunt and the fucking pinning a drawing on the
wall, to fix everything magic was like two of my gripes but
anyway anyway but but yeah so so I am looking forward to
seeing how FNAF 2 goes with like follows up with the
original FNAF and I heard they're making FNAF 3 as well so
it'll be pretty interesting because apparently FNAF 2 teases
FNAF 3 and um
and um and you know i'm curious like is it um i'm curious to
see like um what the fan reactions are to it like the fan
reviews to it because like critics don't will never
understand because the movie is not written for them
obviously like the movie is for the fanaf fans um i'm pretty
sure the first movie like i'm not a big fanaf fan like all i
do is like oh my god you know is that the 1960 is that the
bite of 69 like that's Like I don't even know the the like
surface level of fanap and
So like that's really all I know about fanap is the surface
level so obviously No, it's guys, of course.
It's the bite of 55 guys.
Anyway Anyway So I know the movie is not for me It's not
written for me.
It's written for the fans.
So I'm very curious how the second movie is going to be like
too also apparently What's his name?
PETA from Hunger Games.
I don't know his actual Josh Hutcherson.
I remember his name.
His name just popped up in my head Josh Hutcherson He's
actually he's apparently a fortnight and overwatch gamer
Which is fucking crazy To think about That's like during the
red carpet interview.
He was like oh Oh, yeah, I was playing Fortnite before I was
got here.
He's like, I was almost late.
I was playing Fortnite before I got here, because, like, the
new chapter came on.
I wanted to check out the new map.
And then he's like, oh, my God.
I can't believe he killed off the bus driver.
Like, he was just fucking spending his time on the interview
talking about Fortnite to the fucking interviewer.
And you know, the guy was just like, what the fuck are you
talking about, bro?
We're here for FNAF, bro.
What the fuck?
me yeah he's like he was just like talking about like and
then he did a collab with uh like courage or whatever his
name is I remember it's some fortnight streamer um he
actually recently did a collab with the the courage stream I
don't fucking know I don't really watch fortnight streamers
but he did a fucking fort like a fortnight streamer courage
to promote FNAF um and he also was like oh yeah I've also
been playing overwatch too gotta check out that new
character you know i did not realize he was a fucking gamer
josh hutcherson i did not realize how old oh he's 33.
yeah i didn't realize he was a fucking gamer it's like it's
like when the what's his name i hear his song i always talk
about it um oh what was that what was that famous celeb
famous singer you think he's top 500 a fucking course not
bro like you think he has time no there is a really famous
singer that used to stream fortnite on twitch but he doesn't
do that anymore what was his name um no not post malone he
plays apex um i mean i did i wasn't for those who don't know
um i was in an apex lobby with post
I almost played post I almost played I was almost on the
same team with him too in that lobby I think like twice I
think yeah um back when he used to play apex a lot uh no
pick no yeah really no I'm not I'm not I'm not joking about
that actually like he used to host um apex lobbies all the
time and I got invited to one of his uh one of his apex
lobbies to play like you know playing a server with him yeah
um god what was that who was that singer
what song is that what is that song called the lead singer
of that song used to play fortnite all the time no i'm not
fucking talking about the murderer guys i'm fucking i don't
even i didn't know who that guy was until news articles
started showing up
Brandon, Brandon Yuri.
Yeah, I didn't even fucking know who that guy was until I,
like, news article.
I don't listen to, I'm sorry, but I don't listen to rap a
lot.
So, like, that's why I did not know who he was.
Oh, Brandon Yuri.
Brandon Yuri.
Oh, it's Panic at the Disco.
He's actually a Fortnite He's a, that, bro, that guy's a,
that guy, that's crazy.
That news, those news articles were fucking crazy.
Does he still have his Twitch?
I don't know if he's ever, he streams.
I don't know when was the last time he streamed.
When was it?
Past broadcast.
Oh my God, he has not been around in a long time.
Seven, oh my God, the last time he streamed was seven, yeah,
he's two, go five years ago.
He's too good for us, guys.
he got closer to his 40s and stopped streaming he's like i
got i can't i can't follow i can't be hit with the kids no
more yeah good for him yeah the last time he streamed was
five years ago oh my god it was just like bro i can't i'm
almost in my 40s bro i can't keep doing no i'm not talking
about brandon i'm talking about the murderer guys that's
like people were saying this i'm not gonna say his name out
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna say his name out because i'm not
gonna give him a platform but um people were giving out the
the name they were like oh are you talking about this this
kid who's a fortnite gamer i was like no not him i didn't
even know he was he was like he fucking existed as a person
until like until like um like tweets about him showed up on
my page.
I didn't even know he was a real person until now.
Anyway, I'm going to use the bathroom real quick.
I'm back.
I am back.
Oh, I rated.
Thank you.
Thank you whoever rated me.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you.
Oh, but but yeah.
No, I, I, pooh.
That was a lot of ranting today.
A lot of ranting today.
It grinds my gears.
Oh my gosh, did you guys know?
You had to get that out of my chest.
Do you guys know that, oh god, AI is so fucking crazy now.
But like, I didn't like, okay, so because AI is so hard to
like, especially AI art and AI videos, But it's so hard to
tell if it's AI these days because obviously like computers
are like, you know, like technology is learning more and
more, especially AI.
So every day they're learning because that's all about AI.
They're all just it's like artificial intelligence.
So they're always learning every fucking day.
So they're always improving every day.
And now apparently in Japan, because like even artwork is so
hard to tell if it's AI or not now.
for art that like um like japanese game studios now uh when
they hire uh new uh when they hire new uh like this game
designers or artists to work in their company um they have
to like draw in front of them if they get picked for an
interview they have to like draw in front of them to prove
that they are an actual artist yeah yeah they actually make
them on the spot yeah i was like bro that's looking crazy i
was like that's how like that they have to do that now
because people are like you know like you know people are
like generating ai art for their portfolios or stuff or even
like using it to like you know i i like you know you could
do stuff where like you know you do a sketch and then have
ai fill it out too because ai is crazy now ai can generate
sketches and like generate like like you draw a sketch and
then like have them color over it or anything or have them
line art it and stuff like that so like you know um they
want someone that actually earned the spot to be hired not
have like ai do everything for them there's actually insane
that they have to do that test now because they don't trust
portfolios anymore that's actually insane also speaking of
japan um okay i don't know you guys know this but um you
know i talked about zootopia um and like zootopia is so
fucking popular in asia like you guys have no idea how in
pop how insanely popular zootopia is like in just asia i
swear to god i feel like 80 of the money they earn from the
zootopia brand From Asia
Like Especially merchandising To Like Okay I just found out
That Scrub Daddy Did a collaboration With Zootopia But you
can only get it in Korea And I'm so mad Because I won it
Yeah They have a Scrub Daddy collaboration and it's only
available in Korea and it makes me so angry because I
actually wanted it like so fucking cute I was I almost
ordered it off of eBay because I it's so cute it's not fair
all we have is stitch I looked up I was like oh my god do we
have like do we have these type of collaborations and then a
and it's just literally just stitch that's all we have it's
it's only available in Korea.
I don't understand.
Why don't we have this here?
It's so cute.
Okay, I have to show you guys.
I only know this because I was actually trying to get, I had
to order a scrub daddy to, uh, I think like two days ago.
Okay.
I had to order a scrub daddy two days ago.
And then I was like, oh, there's this utopia one.
Oh, that's cute.
You know, because I like, you know, I like cute things.
So I'm like, oh, it'll be cute.
have like you know you'd have like a themed themed sponge
you know so anyway this is a Korean scrub daddy it makes I'm
so fucking jealous I'm I'm so fucking jealous because it's
not just a regular sponge it's a scrub daddy sponge um
excuse me scrub daddy is an NA invention why the fuck is it
I understand and then when I looked it up in eBay because
you can only get it on eBay it was like fucking uh 20 to 30
dollars I'm like I'm not paying 20 to 30 dollars for a
fucking sponge like
it's a fucking sponge I'm not paying to by the way we're
about shipping too without fucking shipping If I have a
dragoon in Korea right now, please, any Korean dragoons, if
you see a Zootopia 2, scrub daddy, please, please feel free
to buy it for me and send it to my PO box.
And then, and then I'll send you a gift code.
Just write a letter attached to the Scrub Daddy.
I'll give you a gift code in exchange.
I just want a Zootopia Scrub Daddy.
I do not want to pay the scalpers, guys.
I really, really do not want to buy a Zootopia Scrub Daddy
from Scalpers.
All right.
I did, but at least it wasn't a scalper.
It was just a really expensive funny joke.
That's different.
It was a bit
Anyway, so as I said Zootopia 2 is incredibly popular in
Asia like some movie theaters are doing like watch-alongs
Where you can bring your dog to watch Zootopia So there's
like clips of like
the fucking movie theater and like be like uh singing along
to the zutopia sound like zoo zoo oh wait i'll show it guys
yeah it's really cute it's actually really really cute
zutopia 2 dogs it's wild is it this one oh yeah it's this
one i'm not trying i don't want to like fully play it in
case i get copyright strike here you go it's so cute though
For those who want to know, this is not a, I know it's very,
I know that's like the worst part when you're trying to
figure out if it's AI or not, but from what I know, this is
a real thing.
It is not AI.
Thank fucking God.
Yeah, they're showing it for dogs only.
Also, yeah, like Zootopia is incredibly popular in China as
well.
I told you guys about it.
That's why they built Zootopia in Shanghai, Disneyland.
Yeah, they're all dancing, too.
It's so cute.
Oh, it's so fucking cute.
Oh, my.
Yeah, it's just five.
But yeah, other than that, there's also like, and like,
okay, it's actually crazy.
So anyway, remember I told you guys about Pombert?
Fuck Pombert, by the way.
Canva.
Pombert coming in with a goddamn steel chair.
I did not think he was like, like, because like, it's
played, it's voice acted by Adam's...
Like, it's voice acted by Andy Sandberg.
So, I was just like, so when people were like, oh, yeah,
Poverty is so fucking hot.
And I'm like, bro, that's Andy Sandberg from Lonely Island.
Like, like, I don't know.
Yeah, he's a fucking industry plant, bro.
Like, he's a goddamn industry plant.
Because I'm like, bro, that's Andy Sandberg from Lonely
Island.
What the fuck do you mean, hot?
Like, yeah.
But for those who don't know, Popper in Japan is insanely
popular because he's apparently voiced by a very famous
Japanese actor who's very hot.
Because the only reason why I knew about this is because I
forgot this guy's, the actor's name.
Apparently, in Japan, like, majority of the, like, this guy
has, like, an entire, an entire fucking shelf dedicated to
him.
And I'm like, holy fuck!
Because, like, they're banking on the fact that he is
voice-acted by one of the most famous, very hot, Japanese
actor.
To voice him.
So they brought, so they like made so much merchandise of
him in Japan, just fully dedicated to poverty.
Just banking on the fact that he was, he is voiced acted by,
uh, by a hot Japanese actor who's sort of, who's like pretty
famous in Japan.
So like this entire shelf is just dedicated to poverty.
Who voices him in Japan?
Whose voices?
Let me grab the name.
I don't remember his name.
about it let me see I could find it um Yamada Ryusuke I
think that's his name yeah no I I get it yeah it's this guy
Yamada Ryusuke I'm pretty sure I'm pronouncing it wrong um
but apparently he is really famous actor and he voices
Pobrid and um and that's why he has a famous actor and
musician uh yeah Rose to Promise as a teen idol in 2007 so
he's been doing this for a while he is um oh yeah no he his
Wikipedia is long lead role lead role lead role lead role oh
my god wait he's in assassination classroom what the fuck
Was he an assassination classroom?
Lead role.
Yeah, no.
Yeah, he seems.
Oh, he was Edward in Full Metal Alchemist.
Wait, what?
Oh, he played Edward in the live action Full Metal
Alchemist.
Oh.
That's crazy.
Yeah, that was him.
Yeah, he played the live action FMA films.
Yeah, hey, I know that guy.
Is that reference?
Yeah, he's a live-action Ed.
There was a live-action?
Yeah, the Jap, don't worry, the Japanese live-action.
Yeah, this guy.
Oh, wait, made by Netflix.
I knew about it.
I knew about it because, like, you know, people love talking
about the, talking about, like, live-action adaptations.
I mean it's really hard to do a live action of full metal
alchemist to be fair to be fair Chad is like like like it's
hard to make that believable in real life especially with
like like uh doing the like the alchemy shit I feel like
that's really hard especially like with all the effects you
have to do yeah
like the only good live action adaptation you can do from an
anime is literally like slice of life because like i like
like that's what anime that's what animation is for to do
things you can't do with like live action slash cgi disney
um seriously who the fuck is moana the irl the live action
movie for also lion king as well who the fuck is lion king
and the moana live action movie for because like apparently
the moana live action film is apparently oh my god the
chicken is so ugly like moana live action move like oh my
god the chicken in itself is so fucking ugly like what the
fuck what child they're like no it's for the adults what
kind of adult want this
Like, look at the chicken, guys.
Oh,
the chicken.
It does look like just get a real chicken.
Why does...
Just get a real chicken!
Bro, that's just like uncanny valley, bro.
Just get a real fucking chicken.
Oh, my.
That chicken ain't right, bro.
Yeah, I kill it.
Might as well eat that chicken.
Like...
Bro, just get a real chicken.
Why you gotta make that chicken look, it's live action.
Is it supposed to be realistic?
Put it out of its misery.
It looks like it's in fucking pain.
It looks like a goddamn, like, it looks like one of those
chickens that should not have lived to this, like, live to
his adulthood.
Like, the mom would literally kill the chick before he could
grow up.
The mom would, like, look at that chicken and be like, I'm
not...
letting you grow up and just fucking eat it no it's true
what do you mean what the fuck that's what animals do like
like if it wasn't for human intervention a lot of babies
would have got eaten by the moms eating her crush um that's
why i talked about it before but that's why like um a lot of
like um some people are like oh that's so inhumane because
like um some farms they have to like cage the mommy pig
because if they don't cage them and they don't want to
continue if they don't cage them um they will crush the
babies if they don't they don't like the baby they're like i
don't think that child's right and the fucking mama pig will
roll over and crush the pig so they have to like cage it
because some mama pigs will like do that because they're
like that pig ain't right because like she feels it's like i
don't want this baby pig to grow up this child ain't right
like they take matters to their own hands and that's what
like rodents do too um rodents like hamsters they would like
eat their children if like if there's one hamster um that's
smaller than the rest the mama hamster would just fucking
eat it baby because she's like you're not growing you're not
you're not growing any bigger i'm gonna just fucking eat you
yeah they will like welcome to the animal kingdom yeah you
have to separate them immediately yeah especially if they
notice that they're like the weakest they're like i ain't
raising no weak children i ain't raising no weak ass kids i
might as well eat you extra protein um effelion thank you
super chat thank you thank you Disney answering the brave
question what if chickens were what if chickens were real
guys this is like um if chickens were real this is what I
think chickens it's like you know trying to be like this is
what I think dinosaurs would look like Disney is like guys
what if chickens were real this is what I think a chicken
would look like with my interpretation of all the fossils
those we saw in the world.
Mr. Broken Bun.
Thank you, Mr. Super Chat.
Thank you.
If humans didn't intervene, pandas would have died up.
Yeah, no, I've always said pandas literally are alive
because of pretty privilege.
Thank God.
Thank God they're so fucking cute.
They're so fucking cute.
I mean, good, because they are really cute.
As someone that saw that I've seen pandas, IRL, up close,
They deserve it.
Kowalas too.
Look.
I can never see kowalas the same anymore because all of them
have chlamydia.
That's like, like I feel like sometimes I'm even like born
with chlamydia too.
I could never see kowalas the same.
What?
You guys don't know?
Yeah.
All koalas, like majority of koalas have chlamydia.
For those who, fun fact, fun fact.
And also, they're really high all the time because they're
not supposed to eat eucalyptus leaves because eucalyptus
leaves actually make them incredibly high.
So like every koala you see not only has chlamydia, but are
also like, they're like, they're not there.
yeah they're not supposed to eat eucalyptus leaves but i
guess they just really like being high very fun fact
yeah they're all like they're all they're all zoomed out
remember that's so relatable i wish my prayers were real if
i was she is just yo thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you oh yeah back to Zootopia um also other than um
Paver um I know some of you guys were like oh yeah uh the
Kojima thing but yeah um the director of Zootopia invited
Kojima to voice act like a side character as well to like um
as like an Easter egg as well so he's like the fucking
what's it the mole in like yeah Coach Jumbo's in there too
Coach Jumbo's is in Zootopia too I'll just give you guys the
tweet he's literally the the police mole cop um in the film
that's what I'm saying they got everybody in Zootopia too in
Japan Zootopia like all the famous people Zootopia 2 Japan
voice actors I swear to God if I look at the If I look at
the, the cast list of the Japanese cast, it's going to be
like, oh, hey, I didn't know that she was, okay, sorry, I'm
like looking at like the English voice acting roles, I was
like, oh, I didn't know these people were there too.
All right, Japanese cast.
I don't know like the Japanese, who the Japanese actors and
actresses are, but I would assume they're all like
incredibly famous actors and actresses as well.
All right, let me check.
All right, who's the snake?
All right, who voice acts the snake?
Like, I even...
Yeah, no.
The guy who voice acts the snake in Zootopia 2 is...
Okay, these are his roles.
He is Dabi in My Hero Academia.
Oh, my God.
He's Kaima in God.
He's Kaima in...
What is it called?
Um, God, who knows it?
God, the world God only knows.
I love that anime slash manga.
I love the God, um, I love the world God only knows.
That's such a good anime slash manga series.
I fucking love that show.
So I love the manga.
Like, I read the manga before the anime came out and I
fucking love it.
I also have, like, all their songs on my phone.
It's, like, one of my favorite anime I have the I have the I
forgot her name because it was so long ago back when I um I
don't know it was just such a such a it was just a such a
what's the word such an interesting series such an
interesting concept too um what's her name the fucking demon
girl because I have her android too uh lc yeah I have an
android of uh lc so cute she's so cute anyway but yeah she
uh what's his name zenitsu from demon slayers uh dabby from
mahi academia connie from attack on titan he basically this
guy's the snake the snake guy he voice acts the snake
alright how about this girl I'm literally looking up all the
Japanese cast just to see how famous they are.
I feel like they're all very famous people.
Who's this guy?
Wait, who voices the horse?
Who's the voice of the horse?
I don't know who this guy is, but I assume he's very famous
in Japan.
1987 yeah i assume he's oh my god he has he's done a lot
yeah i know the zootopia i mean the first zootopia was our
a-list cast too like for english for i mean not the first i
mean the english cast is also like a lot of a-listers as
well savvy savvy think welcome to tomato farm welcome
welcome and what else i want to talk about there's oh yeah
another thing another fun fact about zootopia apparently
gazelle in the movie was supposed to be like was not
supposed to have an ass
apparently apparently fun fact but gazelle was gonna be was
supposed to be like skinny as fuck and then Shakira was like
no give her an ass yeah see that yeah wait let me see my
concept art yeah apparently in an interview Shakira was like
yeah I told Disney that she must be like thick as fuck or
like she must be thick alright dude Gazelle and then that's
why that's why Gazelle that's why Gazelle is so thick now
bless you Shakira thank you Shakira for doing God's work you
blame it I wish I could find it Gazelle
Where is it?
Gazelle Zootopia Skinny I wonder I wonder I could find Find
a tweet about it It was like a It was a Japanese tweet too
They did their research And then they posted like Gazelle
must not be nerfed I'm not sure what to deal with that
information you say thank you shakira
thank you shakira for your for your service i think it's
this one right
what is shakira okay wait secure a gazelle concept card so i
can find it i want to find thin gazelle I think it's this
this no that's when Shakira got involved please show I'm
trying to find a before and after it was like from an art
from the art book
trying to find it guys guys I'm trying to do you all a
service even go outside i do i literally went out to get
food guys i touch grass and got food got dinner pre yeah pre
and post shakira
her lips don't lie yeah i did i treated i told you guys i
treated myself for beating a video game today i was like
good job toky you beat a video you beat a single-player
video game I'm proud of you you did it girl but I'm so proud
to mess up can't find it guys but I should have saved that
tweet usually I would save like funny tweets I would
bookmark it so I can tell you guys later I'm like looking
through my bookmark but for this one for some reason I
forgot I first For some reason, I forgot to do it.
I forgot to bookmark the pre-imposed Shakira Gazelle tweet.
I'm so sad.
I let you all down.
Let's see.
I want to check something out real quick.
Oh.
Oh, yeah.
I'm, like, looking through my Twitch right now.
You know, like, 6'9", I don't even know who he is, the
rapper.
Bro, that's so...
that's crazy I'm like I that's crazy so he had an interview
recently I booked my business I don't really know I don't
really know like much about him as a person or his songs is
it Takeshi I don't know guys it's yeah yeah Takeshi is six
nine yeah that guy so there was an interview there's an
interview that he did uh that he did recently uh bro that
guy's 29 holy so he did an interview recently and like this
man designed his bedroom to look like a hotel room and he
said he did it because it's easier to cheat so like so this
is what he said i'll quote what he said if i ever cheat on
my girl i'll be like i wasn't in in a hotel i was in my room
because like his room would look like every hotel room that
he stays in because all hotel rooms have like like you know
a signature design so they'll like you know if he shows a
photo of him in his room it'll like they the the girl
couldn't tell Yeah, so, yeah, so, yeah, why are you saying
this on an interview?
So, it's actually crazy.
Like, his room actually just looks like a generic hotel
room.
That's actually fucking crazy.
What a moron?
Okay, bro, like...
I was saying, like...
He's done a lot of stupid things, so I'm...
I am not surprised.
Bro, this is coming from a guy that has face tattoos, guys.
No, is he stupid?
I don't know.
He has several face tattoos.
I don't care.
Like, I know some of you guys are like, hey, Doki.
Like, hey, don't judge a book by its cover.
I, if you get a face tattoo, you're stupid.
Like, I'm sorry.
I will not sugarcoat it.
tattoos is an incredibly super decision to have in your life
because like i don't care you're like oh like this is so
meaningful for me i'm like do you really want to have this
on your face in like 40 years like like i'm just like at
least like at least on your the rest of your bodies on the
rest of your bodies or like um arms and everything Like, you
know, you can hide it too and everything.
But, like, I feel like on the face is just too much.
It's actually, like, it's just, it's just too much.
Say that to Mike Tyson's face.
Bro, okay, do you not remember how he got that?
Okay, when he, I think, like, when he got that tattoo, he
was, like, downhill, right, at that time.
Like, he was literally, like, he was literally, like, on so
many fucking drugs.
and substances that led to him like getting that tattoo.
And like the hangover was his lyric.
Like he was P crazy.
And like at the hangover, when he was like at his lowest.
And the only reason he like picked himself together was
because of the hangover movie.
Because during the filming of the hangover movie in an
interview, he was saying like, bro, I don't even remember
what was going on.
during the hangover films because I was so fucked up that I
forgot I don't even remember what the fuck I was doing or
like what was going on because I was so fucked up on every
type of substance during filming of that movie and that was
the top that was when he realized he had to get his life
together like he had to Like, it's not even method anymore.
He was just...
He was just being him.
He...
Yeah, he injected, like, everything during that filming of
that movie.
Yeah, that punch was real.
Yeah, it took that filming.
Wait, hang over.
I remember reading about that.
I was like, holy shit.
Um...
Yeah, I was a drunk and high pig while filming.
Bro, not, bro, he was blitzed out of his mind.
Was it caught when you're on?
Oh, my God.
There's, like, a word for it.
Bro, not only does he have every substance in his body, he
was also incredibly drunk.
Yeah, cross.
Is it crossfaded?
Yeah, he was fucking crossfaded out of his mind during the
filming of that.
That's crazy.
Oh, bro.
So he said he looked like a pig during the time of filming.
Did not even know he was set to feature in a comedy classic.
He just sticks showing out.
They're like, we gotta go, you gotta do a filming of a movie
real quick.
And he's like, what?
I met the guys in a club.
They were in the VIP section and I said this is where I
normally sit nobody's normally sits here So I went in there.
I'm checking these guys to see what they're doing in my
section And it was Zach the other guy and he said we're
gonna be in a movie with you I said yeah when and he said
tomorrow
And I didn't know as I was drinking and smoking back then
doing drugs So eventually I had to go and do the movie and
it was a success.
Jesus Christ.
Bro, that guy was like, whoa.
I did.
He's like, tomorrow.
What?
No, I'm pretty sure the manager reminded him, but he was not
conscious as a person.
But yeah, like anyway, as I said, I don't care about tattoos
or anything.
don't have tattoos i think like you know some tattoos are
really cool um but i personally i'll never have a tattoo or
have earrings because i'm a fucking pussy when it comes to
pain um like like pussy when it comes to pain and doing
anything to my body so like um but i do think like you know
like the water paint tattoo okay there's like some tattoos
that i think are like really interesting and super cool like
the water paint tattoos and uh um pixel tattoos i think
those um but i would never do that to myself but i will say
i think face tattoos look really fucking stupid i'm so sorry
for any dragons that um that have face tattoos i'm really
it's just like personal preference i just think i just think
like it doesn't look good it just i just personally just
don't think it looks good and i think it's really stupid
more fuss thank you for the super chat Thank you.
Um, I just found the Scrub Daddy KR page, but they say that
Zootopia 2 Scrub Datties are all sold out.
Oh, Doki.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
I told you.
It's all gone.
They took them off.
The Zootopia 2 market is just too good.
They make 90% of their fucking merch revenue from Asia.
Yeah.
The scalpers!
They took them all!
It's just too profitable.
Jordan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
They're too good.
They're too fast.
The scalpers and the real fans.
that's why i'm saying i why is it just exclusive to korea
also another thing i want to talk about but like apparently
people were because like of online shopping um thanks jeff
bezos uh you go jeff bezos jeff bezos i remember this what
was that song in jeff bezos uh bobrams i i I fucking love
that song so much.
Okay, wait, I gotta mute this because I can't let you guys
listen to this because I don't want it to get striked.
What is it?
How do you sing it?
Okay, here's the song.
It's such a good song.
Come on, Jeffrey, you can do it.
Okay, Jeff Bezos' lyrics.
What is it called?
CEO, entrepreneur, Born in 1964, Jeffrey, Jeffrey Bezos.
CEO, entrepreneur, born in 1964, Jeffrey, Jeffrey Bezos.
Come on, Jeffrey, you can do it.
Pave the way, put your back into it.
Tell us why, show us how.
Look at where you came from, look at you how.
Zuckerberg and Gates and Buffett, amateurs can fucking suck
it.
Fuck their wives, drink their blood.
Get him
Bro, it's Jeffrey Bezos, bro.
Look at you now.
I love this song.
It looks right for you in my head sometimes
Cover it when Anyway, anyway, okay, so speaking of Amazon,
so um, so you know like Black Friday So for those who don't
live in America up black friday used to be like this wild
american tradition where right after thanksgiving you go
fight um you go fight other your fellow americans for really
cheap bargains at your local store so apparently like maybe
run over some kids too like at the store with your car with
your shopping carts too because that used that used to be a
thing like people actually died on black friday it was so up
back then like years ago uh before Before online shopping
became a thing in America, right at the day after
Thanksgiving, where you get your thankful about like
everything and your family and your job and your life and
everything.
You know, you start being thankful for like, you know, thank
you.
Thank you for the life you gave me.
And then the day right after Thanksgiving on Black Friday,
they would fight each other and actually get into fist
fights or even like run like run over like employees to get.
the cheapest bargain on like technology or like items or
whatever um or appliances yeah communism come your
consumerism yeah uh shoppers used to actually uh go to war
and people actually fucking died like employees and workers
and like you know um like other like other like customers
would some of them can actually will get like run over by
other people uh just so they could the cheapest bargain
anyway apparently this year was like the lowest it's ever
been for people actually like going going outside to find
bargains to like buy stuff because everyone was just online
shopping because apparently because in Amazon like it has
the similar deals but like they just sent a drone over and
like ship it to you yeah um um so so that yeah so I guess
like it's it's it's good because there's less deaths now um
there's not now there's less deaths going on on Black Friday
yeah so now because you know the things ship to you and you
don't have to go outside and camp out of like a Target or
Walmart
people's the stores started lying about prices now and
pretend to be like fake discounts so like days they would
just like do like a fake 50 off or some shit you know they
would be like oh let me just add like times to the original
price and then like put like slash 50 off so like stores do
that now to like pretend it's black friday so it's not
actually a bargain anymore so that's why wanted to talk
about it because apparently like Target was so desperate was
so desperate to get customers to show up on Black Friday
because like you know I guess like people realize like I
guess like as the years go by like I guess like market
analysis team realize like people don't go out to shop
anymore like malls are dying we all know that like everyone
knows uh malls are dying now like the reason why people go
to malls these days are just to like uh to hang out or for
like the more entertainment malls not for actually shopping
shopping anymore it's just for like either like just to hang
out or just to like there's like entertainment stuff to do
or maybe restaurants or stuff majority of malls just have
restaurants nowadays um it's just food um so um so like I
guess like Target was like yeah nobody really goes to shop
anymore I don't think like there's like less and less
customers in uh um during black friday so what they did to
incentivize incentive to bus that incentivize i can't
pronounce that shit for good english is my first language um
is that they were like the first hundred people who showed
up at the location will get like a special gift bag and a
chance to win like um like the a chance to win like a grand
prize and stuff a lottery so the sorry i'm looking up
opening up the video so apparently the crazy thing about it
is that in the goodie bag like a hundred yeah the target
gift bag during black friday i remember i wanted to talk
about it is that um it had wait what was it is filled with
Oonocards and nerds.
So, so the people, okay, I'm gonna have a screenshot.
So the people who line up, by the way, like, they line up
for fucking hours, by the way, outside, in the freezing
cold, because thank you, global warming, it also works the
opposite way.
So I like how people were like, if it's global warming, why
is it so cold?
Because global warming, although it has, I know it's like
the name, the warming part, is very count like um it's very
counterintuitive because it's like oh it just means it's it
makes things warm but it also makes things really cold it
goes both ways so it makes things really fucking cold during
the winter and really fucking hot during the summer so
anyway anyway it's super fucking cold the day after
thanksgiving and people were like lining up for um for like
hours in the just to get Uno cards and nerds.
And I was like, holy fuck, that is so sad.
This is their goodie bag, by the way.
The first 100 customers at Target during Black Friday.
So what is worse?
Black Friday shopping after Thanksgiving in the U.S.
Boxing Day after Christmas again.
Wow, what?
At least the bag's cool.
I feel like the bag is more expensive than anything else
here.
What is this loot pot level shit?
Um.
But yeah, no, that's like the incentive for people to line
up.
during Black Friday outside.
I feel like Boxing Day was never that bad.
I think.
I don't think Boxing Day ever got that bad in general.
IMO.
As someone that has...
I don't know.
I think people just order online now anyway.
So it never got that bad.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
And also, just off topic.
um this is very off topic but for those who are into like dc
stuff or like uh um they had a new update on the absolute
series regarding absolute joker for those who don't know
anything about dc there's a new dc series right right now
and it's literally like um one of the super villains fanfic
dark fanfic about the superheroes and the other super
villains so it's like his own There's a supervillain named
Darkside, and he made his own, um, his own, like, uh,
original characters, do not steal, uh, fan fiction about,
like, all the superheroes and supervillains in DC, and, um,
there's a new update about his, yeah, his own, like, fanfic,
basically.
Um, oh, the new, no, music, sorry.
Um, I had to look over a video real quick.
Um, and there's an update regarding Absolute Joker, and
apparently he eats babies.
so no apparently like um he keeps a harem of women around
him so he can absorb their babies in the womb like that's
fucking crazy that's actually fucking so fucking evil so i
don't okay i don't know if he's the one that's getting the
women pregnant but i think that's what it's
Joker has a harem of women that he just gets them pregnant
and then fucking absorbs the babies in the womb
so yeah like bro that's just whoa that bro okay like
yeah what the fuck yeah no not on that he's not eating the
baby i mean yeah he is eating the baby but the fact that it
goes to like the next level where he just like absorbs it
from the womb is actually fucking crazy like i would not
have thought of that like why would he do that yeah yeah
that's pretty like literally spawn camping them
yeah no i that was like i was like holy fuck that's that's
That's hardcore, man.
Bro, Dark Side is so edgy.
I mean, his name is literally Dark Side.
I'm literally looking through my bookmarks.
I was like, oh, yeah, I forgot about.
I forgot about all of this.
All the stuff I wanted to talk to you guys about.
Who gets him pregnant?
Joker.
That's the thing.
He keeps a harem of women so he has an endless supply of
babies that he can absorb.
I think that's the fucked up.
It's not just random women.
It's the most messed up part.
It's not random women.
He literally purposely keeps a harem of women so he can farm
the babies.
He's literally farming the babies.
So yeah.
Cool new fun update from the DC universe.
That's going to be owned by Netflix, by the way.
Little pivot over it.
segue to the whole for those who don't know uh Warner
Brothers was just bought by Netflix now so um DC is now now
owned by Netflix and Netflix has creative control over DC so
I don't know I don't know how that's gonna go I I don't I
don't know how that is gonna go because like on one hand
care about like I guess like they don't really care in terms
of like they'll like green light everything but also they
cancel everything too and that what's makes me scared
because you know they've let pass a lot of crazy shit pass
to get green lit and everything but like a lot of shows get
cancelled after like one season too so that makes me scared
really scared because it's like you know um i feel like one
season is not enough for a show to grow on its own because
season one is where people experiment and try to find their
footing on things like trying to find their footing and
where they're at as a show like as a show like trying to
experiment see like you know what works and what doesn't
work and season two is usually where it starts picking up um
yeah so i What they like to do is just if season 1 isn't
like a hit right away.
They just cancel it.
They're just like, what the fuck.
Like, you don't make us enough money.
It's not streamable.
Yeah, or they cancel shit that's popular.
I'm inside job.
I will fucking, I will not let them live it down.
I'm so upset.
I still can't believe they canceled inside job.
It's, I swear, I swear to God, I know I keep saying it.
I swear to God, inside job was an actual inside job because
they got too close to the truth.
And then somebody, like from the higher ups, I'm not, look
guys, I'm not a conspiracy theorist.
I'm not a conspiracy guy.
But like, I swear to God, I think they got too close to the
truth.
And some fucking higher up called up Netflix and was like,
take it down.
Like, because it was such a, it was actually such a good
show.
I was so surprised it got canceled because the writing was
really good.
The characters, everyone was fucking talking about Inside
Job when it was airing.
So, like, I don't understand.
And the clips got, like, millions of views.
So, like, I don't understand how it got canceled.
And so I swear, I swear someone fucking, someone called
Netflix and was like, you gotta, you gotta cancel this.
They're way too close to the truth.
They know too much.
thing put that tin foil hat on
the castle gems like inside job but keep big mouthing it was
super chat thank you thank you it's because it's filled with
celebrities too that's the thing i think big mouth stayed
only because like the creators of big mouth were like super
famous and they just wanted like to make them happy like um
i don't know if you guys know like they wanted to make them
happy and keep the connection too because it's all about
like connections as well and um the creators of bigmouth are
really really really famous hollywood actors and also like
they know everyone too so you know it's like how how adam
sandler got like a was it a five plus year contract i think
it was like 10 year contract was it guys i don't remember
how many years it was it was like five to 10 year contract
with netflix um and like they just give him like it doesn't
matter how shitty the movies are because it was so bad like
you guys gotta admit all the movies that Adam Sandler made
for Netflix was so fucking bad but like it was literally a
paid vacation for him to do whatever the fuck he wants like
I swear to God like the deal the it's just he literally gets
like a paid vacation from Netflix to travel to wherever the
fuck he wants to and then have Netflix hire all his friends
Like, I swear to God, Adam Sandler's friends, like,
maturiate them.
The only way they'll ever get hired is in an Adam Sandler
movie, just because they're friends with Adam Sandler.
And, like, it's literally payday for them.
Like, the trip with him and his homies.
It doesn't even matter how shitty the movie is.
He's already paid.
Now that Netflix has HBO, oh, yeah, also Netflix has HBO, by
the way.
HBO is owned by Warner Brothers.
Hey, sir.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Maybe they can't go back and time and cancel that awful
games of Rosie.
You know what I'm looking forward to?
Maybe they'll fucking get rid of the HBO streaming services.
So finally, all the HBO shows are on Netflix.
Because you know what fucking sucks?
In Canada, we don't have HBO streaming services.
We have to have this other streaming service.
is called crave fuck crave like we don't even get to have
this shit it's not goddamn crave not even on hbo crave
fucking sucks i hate crave yeah crave doesn't even work
right at least though you know what no i you know what fuck
yeah i'm actually happy that netflix got So now actually the
HBO shows are on Netflix now.
Oh my god, we don't at least guys Here's a good thing about
Netflix buying Warner Brothers less streaming services
Less streaming services.
I just need Netflix
But at what cost
The monkey paw is Bless the monopoly Look At least it's Okay
guys Let's look at the bright side of things Like let's look
at them At least it's not owned by Disney Thank God I do not
want them to do what they did to Marvel Like I don't care
what you guys think I think I think Disney ruined Marvel
Like this is my hot take I think Marvel was so sanitized
Because they got bought by Disney That like All the stories
regarding like Marvel like movie and comics are just they're
not that interesting anymore And Star Wars too, I would say
So at least Disney didn't fucking doesn't fucking own Warner
Brothers like so at least that's the bright side Could have
been worse It could have been worse
Disney ruined Star Wars with exception of Rogue One, Andor,
and Mandalorian.
I've never watched Rogue One and Andor.
I've always wanted to, though.
I think Mandalorian was really good.
Until Disney.
Pushed Grogu everywhere.
And then...
And then Pedro Pascal took off the helmet.
Because nobody wants to watch the Mandalorian when he
doesn't wear a helmet.
Like, what the fuck is that?
Bro, that kills my immersion.
bro like we liked you when you kept the helmet on bro like
you were haunted when you had the helmet like stop i don't
want you this i don't want to see you without the helmet man
yeah the helmet stays on he just looks cooler with the
helmet okay does he ruin the mountain delorean with three
things they push grogu on too much and also like just i wish
he was baby yoda to be fair i think like i think baby grogu
would have been much more popular if he was just baby he was
actually just baby yoda i don't fucking care people like
that doesn't make sense doki like in the story and lore plot
wise i think if he kept being called baby Yoda he'd still be
popular the moment they revealed that his name was Grogu
nobody cared about him yeah no one cared about him the
moment they were like his name's actually his name is Grogu
and I'm like I don't fucking care at least name him Yoda Jr
at least that's better like
um Yeah, all the charm gone.
And I was like, Grogu.
Like, all, yeah.
All the charm gone about Baby Yoda.
Um, um, and like, and also, okay, second thing, Pedro Pascal
should have kept his helmet on.
I'm not watching the Mandalorian for his helmet to be
fucking off.
Everyone was watching it because the fucking bounty hunter
outfit was badass as fuck.
And the fact that he took his helmet off ruined it for me.
Um, because, like, it's fine if he does it, like, once or
twice.
every like season like maybe once every season even then
that's like a little bit too much but he took it he added
off like so many times and like the whole mystery of it was
just gone it wasn't like it wasn't interesting anymore like
he should have just i don't care i don't care if he's hot or
not like i don't care i just think that he looks better with
the helmet the character was so much better with the helmet
on um yeah and then like the third point the cgi um luke
skywalker It's like, that was, I don't understand.
Like, I know, okay, the thing is, Disney loves doing defix,
like, loves doing CGI and defix.
Because, like, if anyone ever watched Tron Legacy, they did
that with Jeff Bridges and everything.
Like, they love experimenting with, like, defix and CGI.
But it's so, like, the thing is, they would get actors that
actually looked like the original actors.
And then they would just CGI on top of it.
And I'm like, bro, just use the fucking, uh, use the actors
you scouted out that look like the original actors.
Um, like, like, that's okay.
I feel like they pass.
Like, like, what's the point of you just gonna CGI the face
anyway?
Actually got a good fucking face double, too.
Like, I didn't understand.
That was my gripes about the Mandalorian.
And then George, people were like, like, George, why didn't
you stop Disney from doing that?
And he's like, bro, I don't fucking own Star Wars anymore.
Like, there was a recent, there was a recent panel.
There was a fucking recent panel that George Lucas did.
Like did.
And then people, fans were like, yelling at him, being like,
why didn't you stop this from happening?
Why did this happen and why did that happen?
And then he literally was like, bro, I don't even own Star
Wars anymore.
I sold it.
He's like, stop complaining to me.
I have no control over it.
Like,
he can't do anything.
He has literally no control over Star Wars.
Yeah, he literally got paid.
He's like, oh, yeah, like, okay, wait, I got, let's see.
George Lucas has moved past Star Wars 13 years after selling
it to Disney for $4 billion.
And he's like, I've got a life now.
Wait, let me read the article.
All right.
Let's see.
What does it say?
All right.
Of course I've moved past it.
I mean, I've got a life.
like bro he's just like well i have a lifestyle bro i can't
do anything about it
yeah made us money and peace out
uh lab thank you super chat thank you thank you um imagine
yeah thank you for the super chat thank you thank you he
took his helmet off and the show was ruined just like halo i
mean i don't remember which halo hello hello hello tv show
oh was it amazon it was oh wait it wasn't amazon it was
paramount the fuck does paramount do anymore who owns
paramount i feel like disney's soon right
paramount's next i think paramount's gonna be sold soon
there's no way there's no way They're going to be owned
Future Disney owners I feel like Paramount's next Paramount
got stuck Bro who the okay I'm so sorry George but I hate To
break it to you but Who watches Star Trek anymore?
I'm Sorry Who Who talks about Star Trek anymore?
Okay, okay, okay, this is really fucked up for me.
I'm sorry.
Okay, I'm gonna say something.
I'm gonna say something really, really fucked up, guys.
The one show that was keeping Star Trek relevant was Big
Bang Theory.
guys i know the truth hurts guys but you have to admit the
only one of the biggest reasons why like a lot of like the
generations like after the like the current generations knew
about star trek was because big band theory kept referencing
star trek 24 7 and it kept the show like relevancy alive
because of that and you guys can't be like you can't say
that big band theory wasn't even that popular guys you don't
understand how much of a cultural impact big band theory had
to the normies because okay big band okay
but the jj abridds movies so guys it had 17.31 million
viewers each season they would it was like top 10 show like
every year you guys know i know the truth hurts stop
spreading this information guys i'm so sorry but every
episode that big fan theory i know i you only boo me because
i'm right
you're only booing because you know i'm right
that i feel she's just lying guys are living you guys are oh
my god what's the word what's the word where your guys are
just you refusing to believe me i will fight you they can't
handle the truth
you're all you're you know you're in denial my oh she is
getting canceled
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, sorry.
It's Big Bang Theory and Family Guy because Seth MacFarlane
fucking is also ever since ever since Big Bang Theory ended.
It's only Seth is Seth MacFarlane's time to keep keep the
series alive.
Yeah.
Now it's just now it's just Family Guy holding it together.
pillar left.
That Google Doc where no doc has gotten before.
You guys know I'm right.
You're only booing me because you're in denial.
He also made an animated show, didn't he?
Like an actual Star Trek show.
Seth McFarlane.
No, I actually know Orville.
That's what I was saying.
I actually watched because of it kept fucking they kept
fucking giving me YouTube shorts about it so that I checked
it out
but yeah as I was saying as I was saying Big Bang Theory
kept the show alive to the normies even though it ended
first oh yeah and also Seth fucking it Seth is like I swear
to God I think like the only reason what's named Picard
Picard I feel like literally Seth McFarland has like Picard
on a leash because he's like you're not you mean you'll be
on because he's such a fan boy of Star Trek he literally has
him like like leashed up for all his shows he's like you're
never leaving
Yeah, Patrick Stewart.
You mean Sir Patrick Stewart?
I bet you Seth pays him a lot of fucking money just so he
can be just so he can like have him on American Dad.
Because he's like such a fucking fanboy.
Also, guys.
My first introduction to Star Trek.
You're like, say it dokey to prove my point to prove my
point my very first introduction to Star Trek.
Don't say it.
Don't you dare.
Some things are best left unsaid.
My very first introduction to Star Trek.
but okay okay i'll keep it a mystery guys i'll keep so you
can be disappointed or not in your heads but we all know the
answer we all know the real answer in your heart okay for
the dragoons who wish to cope you can think of a different
answer but you know what the real answer is you
Don't you please say it?
All right, anyway, what was I talking about before?
But that is crazy that...
That's actually crazy that Netflix now owns, like, Warner
Brothers and HBO.
It makes me wonder what they're going to do with that
property.
Say it, break our hearts!
Bird, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
What I'm surprised is that they're not doing anything with
the Star Trek brand anymore.
Not actually doing anything with it.
Star Trek.
What is the newest thing they did for it?
Okay, Star Trek Starfleet Academy.
That's only on Paramount Plus.
Okay, no wonder no one talks about Star Trek anymore.
You can only get it on Paramount Plus.
Like, who the fuck has Paramount Plus?
I feel like it's old.
just like netflix that's what i'm saying i think i think
it's either disney or netflix are gonna buy paramount
yeah it's only on paramount plus me you are you and like 900
people that have the streaming
surface oh is it a perk for working at walmart oh i didn't
know that i don't know it like goes with walmart by the way
we don't have paramount plus in in canada i think Let me
check.
Let me...
I didn't even know that existed as a streaming service.
Oh, wait.
Oh, we...
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Oh, we do have it.
Oh, but the Canadian version is different.
Never mind.
What do we have on there?
To get the full US library, users in Canada have to use a
VPN.
What do we even have on...
When do we even have a Paramount Plus?
Apparently it's just like...
Apparently we have a...
Oh, okay, we don't have the NFL.
But two ones...
I'm sorry, I'm not a sport person.
I'm barely an esport person too.
Yeah, you can subscribe to it, but there's barely any...
Yeah, I was so surprised.
I was like, Paramount Plus?
Like, what?
I just know Crave?
I just know Crave, because that's their, like, alternative
to HBO, because we don't have HBO in Canada.
Or are you barely an esports person?
I don't watch esports that much.
I don't know.
I like watching, like, I like watching gamers.
I'm not like, I don't watch esports in general.
Because it's like, I don't know, it depends on the games.
Yeah, I just want to play.
I'm just here to game It's like how like I like playing
volleyball I like playing soccer But I don't like watching
Like I don't like watching world I'm sorry I know like Like
the timing of that you know Because like the World Cup is
going on Right now other than Other than that The time when
it was in South Africa That one was Okay I will say When I
will say The South Korea World Cup Was hype as fuck I will
say that was hype But other than that I have Oh and And the
Korean And the Korean World Cup What was Because of the I
remember the Korean chat Ba-ba-ba-da-korea Ba-da-da-korea
Ba-ba-ba I say, oh, I don't remember how to say it.
I don't remember the chant, but I love the chant for it.
Like, I remember the chant for it, but that shit was fire.
I didn't know that chant because, um, how do I know that?
Because I used to go to international school, and, um, and
all my Korean friends will do that chant, It was like a hype
chat.
Like I would like sing it.
I would like sing it with them during like when we're doing
sports and stuff.
But I don't remember the lyrics.
I feel like I'm butchering it.
We would like chant that during like sport events at school.
All right, Korean chat soccer.
Now I need to...
Now I want to look it up.
Now I'm curious.
All right, I'm turning this off too.
wait I'm looking it up real quick is that what is it what is
it called is it what is the Korean soccer chant called again
oh piss on Korea is that how it's pronounced okay no that
shit is fire on Korea Oh
Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh Oh oh oh
That's so fun Yeah It's No, it's Pearson.
Oh, Pearson Korea.
Am I like pronounced?
It's so, it's so fun to chant.
It's such a fun chant to say.
It's very fun.
And then I would like, like me and my friends, like during
like matches and stuff, we would be like, we'll chant that
out.
And it was, I didn't know what it meant.
It just sounded, it was so, it was just so hype.
It was just, it was just so fucking hype whenever like you
chant it.
It was like, Asi, Asi, Asi.
Oh, oh, I love these, like, I love these like, like sport
chants because they're all supposed to be so fucking as
like, Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, it's just so fun.
Yeah, it's pretty hype.
and the australian chat um is one of my favorite like uh
like sport chants and everything but yeah like i would say
like the only two sporting events that i was like super
hyped about and like um and uh uh and like i actually
watched like sporting events was literally like the um what
was it the like I said, the World Cup in South Africa
because it's like, because of Shakira and the Vuvuzela's
walka walka oh and also the octopus it's because of the
octopus by the way but those who don't remember the famous
World Cup octopus came from the South Africa the South
Africa World Cup so I think it was an octopus, yeah the
octopus guys oh my god that's a throwback the very the
craziest uh uh animal prediction thing so paul the octopus
apparently predicted like i remember this when it was
happening um he would like he would successfully predict the
winner of each match during the world cup And everyone's
like, whoa, Paul Heavy was cheering on for Paul.
He's like, Paul, who do you think is going to, he was like a
Magic 8-ball.
He's like, who do you think is going to win the World Cup?
And he somehow managed to get every fucking pick right,
except for like, what the last game, right?
I don't remember.
It was like, it was either the last game or the last two
games.
fucked up but he was he literally had like he was like he
was a prediction master he was a savant of like soccer uh
yeah i think he got every prediction right until the i just
said my finals are the finals i don't remember imagine the
amount of money people like imagine the amount of money
people won by betting against paul Yeah, he had a fucking
streak going.
Also, Waka Waka, too.
That's, like, the reason why I think South Africa World Cup
was the most hyped, like, sporting event ever.
Like, it just, everything just led to it.
Literally, Waka Waka, Vufu Zetas, and fucking Paul the
Octopus.
Waka, Waka is, like, the fucking best, like, sporting, like,
World Cup Sonic ever done.
I need to listen to it.
battles
do you guys know Shakira so the Waka Waka song oh my god did
she really no sense it's Africa walk on a a zombie omina
zombie you are this is africa this is such a good song i
feel like okay the thing is sakira i feel like all okay this
is a hard take but like shakira's songs i think like
shakira's songs they all sound very similar but they're all
really good they all sound really similar but yet i feel
like it doesn't matter to me because they they're they're
bops though they're they're pretty good even though they all
like i would i would keep taking the same song over and over
again like she figured it out you know she figured out the
system she knows what it's like what's her name megan
trainer trainer like her songs all sound the same but like
she she figured it out she knows she cracked the code it's
like her and megan they both like know what people want like
from them yeah don't change what isn't broken i've
never listened to spanish version but i grew up with the
english version Waka Waka A-A-A Bada-na-na-na-na-na-na
Because this is Africa Bada-na-na A-A Waka Waka A-A-A Okay,
I love that song I love that song But like I said, yeah
Those two events Are the only events I know When it comes to
sports But yeah, I don't care much about Um I don't care
much about Like Are there's Like I know there's a World Cup
Right now Uh I know there's a World Cup right now going
That's about to start I don't even know where the fuck it's
gonna be It's gonna be there soon World World Cup Soccer Or
football FIFA We all know FIFA's like corrupt as fuck
They're like
It's like It's like a It's like we all know But we pretend
we don't see like
is it actually in the is it actually held in the states
right now wait where is it right now
just casually mentioning a little fun fact oh no it's like
no we see it
oh next one but this year isn't this year isn't it World Cup
this year Or is it next year?
I know people are...
Oh, it's next year.
People are prepping for it right now.
Don't keep trying to see how many fandoms you get this off.
Where the fuck are we gonna have it in Canada?
Bro.
Our team does not do that well.
Women's soccer, on the other hand.
We do well in that.
I don't know.
I don't know about...
Okay.
World Cup soccer.
Canada.
I don't know about like our soccer team in Canada.
Do we do okay?
Canada at the FIFA.
All right, let's see.
Overall record.
Did not enter.
Did not qualify.
24th.
31st.
Qualified as... Yeah, no.
Yeah, I know I remember because I get disappointed whenever
i when i started when i was watching when i try to watch uh
yeah no this is an incredible record from canon this is so
sad i'm sorry this actually okay i'm so sad this is pretty
sad to look at because i was like we do are we ever had a
good year because i like i know i don't pay i don't pay much
attention like i do pay attention to um to like you know if
we do well I pay attention.
So that's why I don't pay much attention to FIFA World Cup.
Because, like, Canada's never sort of...
They've never really done well.
We tried, and that's all that matters, right?
So, wait.
Let me...
Okay, let me show you guys the record.
It's pretty sad.
Not, like, looking at it.
Okay.
uh here yeah it's just like have we done okay
did not qualify did not and it did not fucking from 1990 to
2018 did not qualify
okay guys we qualify we're co-host guys we are in from
that's not bad you made the show twice guys guys but now we
mandatory qualification because we're hosting we're in by
default because it's held in our country
let's go it's like America America and Mexico brought their
like little brother along it's like it can make him like can
to join us like mom said we had to bring him along we're
like yeah we're in we're in people
Mom said like we have to bring Canada along.
Can he join us?
Mom says Canada gets the play.
Yeah, we got its co-hosts.
Mexico bringing both its siblings.
Hey, hey, hey, look, look.
Like, America also has, like, a really good female soccer
team, too, okay?
Like, do we have a decent female soccer team?
I'm pretty sure.
Like, I've seen our female soccer team do well.
All right, let's see.
Oh, wait, no, that's 2025.
That doesn't count.
I'm talking about overall results.
Yeah!
That's pretty...
Okay, that's...
Do we have a good record?
No, we don't.
Okay, shh.
Look, look.
We're trying our best.
Chikori, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Make it by Doki Merch in Korea.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I have Doki Merch at the Korean anime store right now.
I just wanted to go check that out.
All my drag villains in Asia.
We do have Doki Bird merch in the anime stores.
That's like the Korean collaboration that we did, I think,
like last year.
So if you are in Korea, yeah, there's no, unfortunately
there's no international stripping.
But if you're in Korea, you'll be able to find it when we
did the Korean collab a year or two.
I think like a year and a half ago is there.
But yeah, thank you for the super chat, Chakori.
Thank you.
Look.
Look, there.
Canada at the...
Look, I...
Oh, okay, wait.
Okay, look.
The thing is, Canada at the FIFA Women's World Cup, we
qualify.
You can't say that.
It's still pretty decent.
Because Canadian Women's FIFA World Cup team qualified.
qualified compared to the to the FIFA World Cup that's huge
and then and in 2003 they got fourth place look I know 2003
was 20 years ago but it's it's counts it counts it fucking
counts that's huge for this let's go and if you're asking oh
how many teams where is there um there were 99 teams in 2003
okay 20 years ago 99 teams tried out for the FIFA Women's
World Cup and Canada not only qualified we got fourth place
we don't talk about the other records we don't we still
qualified we still qualified it might not have been fourth
place but they still qualified
This unfortunate record that we have This is an unfortunate
record But look Look We're hosting so you can't get rid of
us now So we got in by default this time around This time
around Our big brothers vouched for us so we're in the
record should never been shown yeah we have home field
advantage thanks big bro guys maybe we'll we'll have a
miracle guys you don't know that maybe a miracle will happen
still know that oh my god in 2030 is portugal spain and
morocco that okay is spain i swear that's i hope like spain
win like spain oh my god okay that's hard it's like spain
and portugal and and morocco that's like a insane like squad
for the host countries who won during that all right wait
who won okay knockout stages oh it was Argentina looking at
stats it's just interesting I like to see who wins
it's just really interesting to see yeah it was uh
Messi in Argentina oh yeah it was Messi's year that's crazy
how old is messy I feel like he's like old now he's like 38
holy fuck oh my god bro that man's 38 he's almost in his 40s
guys I don't know if you guys know how big a soccer field is
but when I used to play soccer that shit is I was so happy I
was a goalkeeper up
because like all right here's like for those who don't play
soccer and was like it's not can't be that big like for
those who don't know how big a soccer field is like that's
crazy that he's able to still do this at in his 40s like
that look how tiny this person is
like no fit football fields are fucking huge like yeah yeah
that's um like oh my god
they look like ants like bro like how many people can line
up on the lid so the fact like so you guys are like yeah but
he's not running back and forth it's still a lot of running
even like half-field is he a forward or midfielder oh sucks
for the midfielders not gonna lie not gonna lie and like by
the way for those who don't know how long a game is okay i
don't know if it's okay how long is a game and so i just
don't want to be like wrong but it's like two 45 minute
halves so like that's like yeah that's like 90 minute a 90
minute match running back and forth that's like doing like
um running back and forth back and forth back and forth and
also having enough energy to fucking kick the ball like that
shit that shit is a lot and being 40 and doing all of this
too that's a lot of fucking running in your 40s like i say
like you know like like in basketball, I feel like you can
um, so be like, how old is um, a bronze, okay, so like you
can be like, well, the bronze James is 40, but a basketball
court is like, okay, I'll let you guys know how this is the
size of a basketball court.
Like, I'm sorry, but this is the size of a basketball court.
Okay.
I'm sorry Like this is a soccer field Yeah Yeah Yeah it's a
lot small Like I would say like I feel like you know you can
be 40 You can be 40 And oh yeah Basketball has like more
timeouts too But like even like Like a basketball court is
like this size Like even then It's like this size Like but a
soccer field It's fucking crazy yeah
grass is easier but it depends on the shoes the thing is
like basketball shoes is all about the pumps because like
okay the reason why I know so much about this because I did
sports um I did a lot like I did I was in varsity for um I
did uh I did varsity for uh soccer basketball volleyball um
and in badminton um and like no grass is not easier it's not
but like running cleats is like a lot of work like as
someone that like running in cleats versus wearing in like
specific basketball shoes like run like basketball shoes for
it so like run especially like i almost twisted my ankle if
the grass is just fucked up and even if the grass is like a
little fucked up that's why they have to like check the
grass um depending on like how what field you are they
people have to check their grass all the time Because, like,
if the grass is, like, even a little bit, like, bumpy, it
will fuck your cleats up.
Like, it will fuck your ankles up.
Because it's not fun to run in.
Yeah, because the earth is always uneven.
So that's why they're always checking the field to make sure
the field is even and everything.
So it's not fun.
Yeah.
So that's why I'm like, it's very impressive to see that,
you know, is Ronaldo also for Eddie?
It's very impressive.
Physically incredibly fit to be able to do this like in
their 40s like running back and forth in their like you can
say that They're not running all the way back, but it's
still a big fucking field And also whoever's the midfielder
like it sucks because like you know strikers always get the
most attention Just like you know, they're always scoring
the goals Because they're always scoring the goals and
everything you You know, getting a point is really, really
fucking hard in soccer.
So, like, strikers tend to be the most popular player in the
team.
Like, you know, because, you know, cooking.
So, but, like, yeah.
But, like, being a midfielder, like, having to go, like,
yeah, running back in form, that shit must be so fucking
tiring.
Like, that shit must be hell.
I was playing goalkeeper.
I was doing, like, why?
didn't know this so i told i did varsity i did varsity
sports in high school and middle school so i was very active
i was very active in high school and middle school before i
like went to gaming um that's why i have really good
hand-eye coordination because i was really good with my
hands like what like with my hand-eye coordination um so
like um you know that's why i was a goalkeeper too because
like i was able to catch balls really well and like i did
get okay i would i told you I told this story before but I
had no fear I was like I am as a goalkeeper I had no fucking
fear and I would actually run in like if I see if I have
like you know like you know you're all about like checking
your like odds and stuff so like I was that goalkeeper that
I will run up to the striker and just die for the ball and
just do like the huddle thing and for those who know soccer
like you know you'd go you do straight dive and just huddle
like you do that and huddle and grab the ball I would I did
I do that um so I actually have no fucking fear and I have
got kicked in the head like once I by like by one of like
the most famous striker like during a tournament where like
um I have got kicked in the head once by uh the the most
famous striker in like one of the schools we competed to get
like in the tournament we competed in and there was this one
girl who was like one of the most scariest players i've ever
played against and everyone knew her because she was like
the most talented like like she literally got a scholarship
uh for university for playing soccer um and it was very
impressive because she got scouted in an international
school environment um which is very hard for that to happen
because like like like you know normally you don't get
scouted if you're in international school um because like
you know like so she literally got a scholarship for playing
soccer um yeah i got kicked by the scholarship leg i ruined
this explains a lot thank you those super chat to you thank
you thank you um um um so like so like yeah no uh she was
like the most well-known player um during the division like
in the division i was in like with all the schools competing
um and i was like we were good friends though i like being
friends with like people in other schools because i thought
it was like you know because we were it was like all
international schools competing against each other so it was
always really cool making friends with like other
international students from different schools and stuff
because we always see each other we the only time we can
ever see each other was during like uh during tournaments
and stuff so i was like you know i was like i hanged up with
like i hanged up with her a lot too after like i hanged up
with her a lot like before and after uh during the
tournament um but yeah what was i saying before um but no
like um that's why I'm like, I'm really impressed.
I'm really impressed with how, you know, how they're able to
stay so fucking consistent, even though they're like in
their 40s.
Cause holy fuck.
Like, like, you know, as you get older, like, you know, you
hear about how they'll have like back problems and muscle
aches and everything.
So I'm like, power to them.
Like, power.
to these people can you even run still I don't know I don't
know I don't remember what it's like to run what
do you mean I don't know because like when you ever get a
chance to run you know I feel like the older you get The
less you have to run.
You know what I mean?
Like, there's no reason to run anymore.
It's fun.
Oh, yeah.
Unless you want to, you know, do cardio and stuff.
Yeah.
I guess for, like, cardio and stuff, you know?
I just like the bike.
I like biking more than cardio.
Yeah, why?
Also, like, I just like doing the biking stuff.
stuff will
you participate in a mirror fuck no i'm sorry but as as a i
don't find enjoyment in running i know there's some people
that find enjoyment in running because of the adrenaline
rush they get from running i'm not unfortunately i'm not i'm
not that type of person but you're like well but doki you
did all those sports back then like why did you do it you
didn't enjoy like the from act from this i liked winning
that's really it i like i only participated in those in
those teams because of the rush of winning like i hated
practice i just liked winning in the tournament environment
fucking practice sucked because you're not actually
competing yeah i like the competition i just hate the
fucking lead up to it This wasn't fun.
Because you're like, you're like, it's just like, you can't
win at, exactly.
You can't win at practice.
Yeah, I don't get runners high, whatever the fuck it's
called.
And the thing is, I did enough marathons as, you know, like
not marathons, but you know the mile run.
Fuck that shit.
I did enough mile runs in school.
I don't need to do that in my free time.
with the rest of your team yeah but it ain't the same ain't
the same you know why because like okay this is the fucked
up part like it's just it's not the same because in practice
matches you're not even playing against the best players
like you know okay if anyone's ever been on a team during
practice matches what they do is they put the main team as
like team a and then they're fighting against the b team so
you're not actually you're not even fighting like you're
like literally
during practice because you know you know they want you they
want the main team to have the chemistry yeah it's the good
players versus the bad players the subs so you're not even
the reserves so you're not even playing the actual good team
so it doesn't feel like good practice
so the only way so we did have like a practice school like
we do have a school that we would practice against sometimes
which was fun but that was the only time when practice was
fun like
bias yeah oh no but like okay but but in soccer in soccer um
in soccer it was the only sport that actually had good
practice in because they would put me as the goalkeeper of
the b team so you know so you know because the a team would
have more like i can have like more chances to like actually
like that they will put me on the B team so I can practice
against like the A team strikers because like I don't need
to be on the A team to practice against like I don't need to
be an A team to practice goalkeeping that's the only time I
got good practice and then I at one point okay for those who
didn't know I was like the most I my goalkeeping abilities
back then was so scary slash good i know you're like wow
doki so humble but no i i'm i'm really serious about this
because it's like i was really really good at goalkeeping to
the point where like the the male the boys team would ask me
to practice help in for their b team goalkeeper uh or for
their a team for their a team goalkeeping so they can have
like um so i can have more practice and also like Also,
like, they can have, like, a decent goalkeeper to practice
against with, too.
No, I didn't get kicked in the head there.
But it was really good practice as well.
I would, like, if the girls didn't have practice then, the
boys team would ask me to, like, the coaches and the boys
team would actually, would ask me to, like, be the
goalkeeper for the A team to help for practice.
Now look at me.
I sit at home.
I use my hand-eye coordination for gaming now for Marvel
rivals.
I use it for Marvel rivals now.
Relocated.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I really appreciate the support, man.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you Happy birthday dear relocated shrimp
Happy birthday to you Yay!
Happy birthday!
I mean, I'm fine with it, less running Because like they
would make me run Even though I was a goalkeeper
That's the worst part They would make me run Even though I
was the goalkeeper And I was like, well, you're gonna get a
run for it Well, I don't need a run for it
uh carico think of a super chat thank you thank you i don't
i think i've heard of this i have heard of the show i know
it's really sad but i've never watched it cardio win games
cardio fucking sucks i don't need cardio i have v-tubing i
heard it's really really good all right guys for three hours
i'm so sorry i'm so sorry to my manager because i was
supposed to do some work stuff too after this um um oh no oh
no okay okay i gotta go now i got i have to go now guys
there's some work stuff i had to do um i lost track of time
because i had so much fun just yapping to you guys um sorry
i had a lot of fun hanging out with my dragoons as always
yeah i'm had your message me was like um there was this
thing you were supposed to do and i was like oh fuck i
didn't realize the time i'm sorry um hey guys hey guys i
always have a fun time hanging out with you guys dragons i i
don't know i fucking yapped so much about so many fucking
random things today um and uh you know it's just fun hanging
out my dragons it's just talking about whatever whatever
that's on my mind today.
I don't know.
I've fucking yapped so much.
I don't even remember what topics crossed my mind today.
But hey, guys.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, guys, you deserve
it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
Yeah, the tangents today was all over the place.
I feel like I sidetracked a lot.
sidetracked a lot today but you know it was fun it was fun i
always love just you know just talking about whatever is on
my mind with no filter or sensors uh but i hope you guys
also have fun just listening to me or like just um listening
to me or just hanging out in general um and thank you all
for the support as always bye guys bye